And
three,
two,
one.
No.
Yes.
Okay.
It's a lot.
It's been fucking up a little bit lately.
How are you man?
Thanks for having me.
My pleasure.
Yeah,
you brought me a nice conspiracy book.
I want you back.
I want you to
get bored with it.
I know.
I just had a lunch with Eric von,
Danica.
Uh,
he's the author of Church of the Gods.
The last two hours we've been talking to ancient aliens.
I was deep when I was like in,
in my late teens.
I was deep in Zachariah stitching and Inaki filium I'm pronouncing it wrong.
That lead my thing.
Nephilim,
planet x Nibiru all over.
Yeah.
That's a lot of the conversation we had today at lunch.
It's very interesting.
The problem with someone,
I mean,
it's not that he's not a dishonest person,
I'm not saying that,
but the problem with anybody that is involved with like a book like this is that
you're so all in,
you're so committed to this idea.
Like I asked him,
the first thing I asked him,
I was like,
what is the most compelling piece of evidence?
And,
um,
he said the,
the tablet and [inaudible] I don't know if you're aware of that one.
Yeah.
The one of the,
the Aztec Aztec or a mine I guess the mind guy.
It's mine.
Um,
who's laying back.
Uh,
it looks like in some sort of a throne with five below him and he's manipulating
these knobs and shit.
And that means that aliens landed and seeded them with technology.
Yeah.
They always make a little bit of a jump.
It's a big one that's like evil Knievel.
It's a little bit of a jump between that bird is really a symbol of a flying
saucer.
I've heard that too.
I've heard that one like that bird.
And I'm like,
well,
let me ask you a question.
Why didn't they ask you a flying saucer right into the cave?
And they're like,
well,
let you don't know how things work.
The more interesting ones and the art depictions that there's some really
ancient depictions of people that look like they're in these flying saucer type
things,
like flying through the air and they're in some sort of a like,
you know,
some,
some painting.
Yeah.
Those are,
those are really interesting cause like what were they trying to say?
Like what were they,
what were they depicting?
And those things.
I mean it's all very interesting,
but I think you,
and you've had Graham Hancock on.
So to me when I heard him,
I was like,
that makes more sense that we were just a civilization that had reached an apex
and it got wiped out by some cataclysmic event and then we had to rebuild.
But is does he think that we got all of our technology from other worldly
sources or no,
not really.
It doesn't,
it doesn't.
Ram is much more in line with this.
Um,
this theory that doctor Robert Schoch has been putting forth,
he was one of the weirder ones that I've had on the podcast.
First of all,
because he's a rock solid geologist,
professor at Boston University,
like really well established.
His credentials are,
you know,
they're,
they're as good as it gets.
And he was saying that he thinks that there was a mass coronal mass ejection
somewhere around 12,000 years ago and it was literally raining lightning all
over the world.
And decimated the population of land mammals and,
and people.
Just what got the dinosaurs?
No,
no,
no.
This was way late.
I apologize.
This is like my bad.
This is a,
they think in the neighborhood of 12,000 years ago.
They think this is recent.
Yeah.
This is what Graham Hancock's work indicates as well.
See,
Graham Hancock and him were together on the Sphinx because Robert Schoch was the
geologist they brought in to examine the erosion marks on the temple.
That's Sphinx.
Yeah.
And his conclusion was that this is the result of thousands of years of
rainfall.
Right.
The problem with that was the last time there were significant rainfall in the
Nile Valley was 9,000 BC.
So you'd have to have thousands of years before that to create these deep water
based fishers or water created fissures to,
they're saying the Sphinx was there a lot longer than we imagined.
Yeah.
So that coincides with a lot of these,
the,
the people that want to push back the dates of civilization,
what they think is that it all points to something big happening at the end of
the ice age.
Yeah.
So something big happening between 12,000 and 10,000 years ago.
Why don't mainstream scientists just go now?
I'm sure there's a reason for this.
And I think there's a reason that mainstream thought leaders in any area don't
allow the fringe in why?
What's the big thing here with keeping these guys?
Is it that they would just have to go back and relook at every history book?
Well,
in the beginning there was nothing,
right?
So when these guys were proposing this,
there was very little evidence,
but now that evidence is stacking up and there's all these ancient structures
that they're finding like go Beckley Tepi yeah.
If once they found that one and they realize that it was intentionally covered
up 12,000 years ago.
So this is like,
this is undeniable.
Everyone agrees on it.
Yeah.
And so then they have to say,
okay,
well then hunter gatherers must've made this cause 12,000 years ago.
That's all we had was a hunter gatherers.
But it's really sophisticated construction and it's very difficult to do.
And they're enormous.
And they have three dimensional animals that are carved into them,
which means they actually had to carve away the outside to create the animal.
Instead of carving the animal into the stone,
they actually carved the stone out around the animal.
So these animals are like climbing on the outside of these stone columns.
It's really weird stuff.
Yeah,
but who the fuck knows I,
I'm,
I lean more towards cataclysmic disaster because there's so many of them that we
know for sure have happened.
Right.
But between the one 65 million years ago in the Yucatan that killed the
dinosaurs,
just reading about the ARkStorm that's going to hit la,
which he'll just be 60 days of rain Wednesday,
it happens every 200 years.
I mean,
I,
you know,
this is an article I read every 200 years.
La in the area
gets 60 90 days of rain and everybody has to move and things.
This is supposedly what somebody sang,
somebody with a bunch of panicked comedians who are all thinking about,
they're worried about the ARkStorm now it's fun to think about stupid the best.
It's thinking about like conspiracies and big foot.
Yeah.
Ufo shows and shit like that.
It teaches you how to think a little,
like when I was a teenager,
I was smoking weed with my buddies.
Like we would,
you'd have to research these things.
You'd have to cross reference information.
You couldn't just swallow the narrative.
You had to literally go well and then you'd have to use critical thinking to go,
does this make sense?
Would this have happened?
Could maybe could Lee Harvey Oswald at?
What about,
you know,
would he have acted alone?
Hah.
You know,
you have to think about all these things.
I mean,
I,
I do think since Trump got elected,
conspiracy theorist had been demonized and nobody talks about that.
This is a little bit,
well,
it was always going on.
It was even before that there were being demonized.
But yeah,
for sure.
Cause worried about the other groups,
which is fair.
I get that there's the people in the cages.
No good.
I'm not for any of that.
People in the cage,
they will.
The kids in the cages is not good.
What do you mean the family separation?
Oh,
all the course.
Real stop.
But I think that people think that conspiracy theories got Trump elected,
so now it's like cool to hate conspiracy theorists or people that are like,
let's take another look at this.
There's so many factors that got Trump elected,
right?
And it was a perfect storm of people getting,
getting fed up of political correctness.
Someone coming along that's not a politician.
You know,
the system is so rigged that after a while you just like Jesus Christ.
How many more of these fake puppets were going to put an office?
There's,
I say this to comics.
I'm like,
everybody's done a show where everybody goes out and bombs with their material
and then one guy gets up and just goes,
fuck this and screams and yells and destroys because that's what the room wanted
the whole night.
They wanted somebody to come up and just realize how fucked everything was and
how nobody was having a good time.
And that's kind of what Trump was.
Trump was the guy that came out and just riffed.
He went out there with no material.
He just went out there and rift and he went and,
and I,
when I heard,
and I'm sure you've seen this speech where he talks about Ben Carson going after
his mother with a hammer and trying to stab his friend.
This was one of the funniest things.
He was speaking and he was given a stump speech.
I don't know where it was.
I think it was,
wasn't in I will,
but he was referencing Iowa and he's talking about Ben Carson's book and that
Ben Carson had admitted to going after his mother with a hammer and trying to
stab his friend with an,
I mean,
these are,
these are in and Trump is talking about it.
Me and my friend would driving,
uh,
at in New York City.
We were laughing so hard.
I said this guys,
I said,
he's going to win.
I'll tell you why he's going to win.
I cannot stop watching this.
I can't,
I am so fixated by the idea that there's a guy like this on the national stage
and he sang whatever he won.
There was something intoxicating about that.
And a lot of the things you were saying were horrible,
but he was saying them.
And then on the other side you had Hillary Clinton who was just,
they scripted Oh,
careful person.
And I'm like,
it's just boring to me.
I'm like sometimes he entertaining person wins because you can't take your eyes
off them.
Well in this case for sure,
I mean in the that it was a perfect,
you know,
polar opposite between him and her,
no experience versus vast amounts of experience.
No real experience in the real world versus vast amount of experiences.
Yeah.
I mean there was a lot going on between the two of them.
It was a,
it was,
it's,
it's a bad way to choose
runs really.
It's very bad to look at candidates and go,
who's the most entertaining?
Well,
it's also a bad idea to have one person,
right?
It's a bad idea to have this,
this same system that was in place back when there was fucking,
you know,
a thousand people here.
But I think we've really dealt,
like we have one person that seems like we have one figurehead,
but we have kind of this permanent political class of people.
Yeah,
a nexus of powerful institutions where you have career politicians,
career diplomats,
career military service people that kind of don't leave.
So I think that's one of the reasons that we haven't changed the system is
because one person can't ever do that much.
Even though Trump is wild and crazy and he's done a lot of bad things.
I don't think he would be allowed to deviate from many of the policies like
that.
His predecessors had kind of established,
I think that like the American government,
and that's why this the like the deep state,
which a lot of people ridicule.
It's an undeniably true thing.
I mean,
our policies are not just one guy gets into office and he goes,
here's how it is.
Right?
I mean it's the result of a lot of,
you know,
private corporations lobbying,
forming,
all kinds of forming an agenda and a non democratic way.
You know,
they're not accountable at a lot of these people that work at the CIA or the FBI
or the NSA.
A lot of them are appointed.
They're not elected.
Right.
We have no oversight.
Um,
we have,
I think it's 22 intelligence agencies now.
It's really that money.
I mean,
it's something absurd.
How many could you name the FBI?
CIA,
NSA?
Uh,
probably DEA,
DEA,
and intelligence.
I wouldn't say it's an intelligence that they probably have intelligence
capabilities.
I would imagine.
FBI,
CIA,
NSA,
uh,
there's one and yet the dia,
director of intelligence,
the Pentagon.
I mean,
I don't know if that's an entire agency,
but I think it,
I mean,
I think it has the capabilities,
but we have all of these different,
I don't know if it's 22,
but it's a lot.
And they're all competing with each other.
They're all competing because they all want money.
They want budget.
They all want,
and that's the thing that people talking about,
the deep state.
It's like we got them all.
Yeah.
Look at these guys who they are.
Jesus.
Here are all the people that are,
you know,
what?
Listening.
Excited.
Yeah.
The fucking space troops that we have space that's going to be good and why not?
Why not a space for it will eventually,
right?
Eventually you're going to have to have it.
Oh yes.
Why not have it?
Now we have,
I don't know what the national geospatial intelligence thing does.
They can't be any more relevant than space force.
Click on that one.
National Geospatial Intelligence Agency shouldn't be any less important than the
space force.
Who the fuck knows how many people were working on employs 16,000 thousand look
at it.
Look at their motto.
Scroll down a little bit.
Scroll down.
No earth show the way.
Understand the world what that's founded in [inaudible] 96 yeah,
Clinton probably did.
It's probably where he keeps his chicks.
I mean this,
right,
but this is,
this is what I mean.
Like what the hell are these people doing now?
What is it?
16,000 employees with their motto?
No,
the earth show the way.
Understand the world.
That sounds like a year like on a yoga studios,
you know?
I mean,
it's absurd,
but they get billions of dollars to do whatever.
Listen,
put that back up there with the description.
Look at,
we're good.
It says there,
it's a,
it's under the United States Department of Defense and Intelligence Agency of
the United States intelligence community with the primary mission of collecting,
analyzing and distributing geospatial intelligence in support of national
security,
which is why,
what does that mean?
What the Hell is geospatial intelligence?
I mean this is what I mean.
This is insane.
And if any,
if you ask a question,
if you go,
well,
what do these guys do?
People yell at you and they started with,
Oh,
you're the,
you're a conspiracy theorist and you don't know this.
I just want to know what geospatial intelligence is.
It's probably something simple and now I'm going to look like an idiot.
It says it's intelligence about the human activity on earth derive from the
exploitation and analysis of imagery and geospatial information that describes,
assesses and visually depicts physical features and geographically referenced
activities on the Earth.
I mean this is,
I think that's how we would know like that North Korea has a bomb size of
satellites.
Satellite Imagery I think.
I guess,
well,
there's probably a satellite agency too.
I think we've uncovered a scam.
I think we've uncovered a pretend agency that nobody in,
that there's a guy right now panicked in the table.
Spatial 16,000 other employees going,
shit,
we're going to have to find a real job.
We would study and shipping docs from space.
Yeah,
we just got outed.
Yeah.
What did they
just got outed on?
Rogan is completely [inaudible].
It's not really there.
That was an actress.
100%.
That's an actress.
But this is what I mean,
if you could,
if you look into this stuff,
it starts to get crazy.
The amount of people that are doing
things,
we have no idea what they're,
I mean,
10.
I just did a private Gig at the Bethesda country club in Maryland.
Okay.
It's,
you know,
I'm still doing it.
Private gigs say,
but you gotta you know,
it is got to do what you gotta do.
How to do what you gotta do.
I go to the Bethesda Contra called Maryland.
Um,
it's the entire 10 counties around Washington DC are the wealthiest counties in
the world.
I mean,
in,
in our country,
they,
and it's not because they're selling crab cakes,
you know what I mean?
It's all defense industry,
Raytheon,
uh,
you know,
DynCorp things you've never heard of.
And they're all there.
And they were,
it was a good gig.
They were funny.
I got up and I was like,
what are we,
oh,
we a carving up Venezuela.
They all,
after all clapping there in new way,
you know,
they liked it.
They,
some people get mad.
I was,
like I said,
last week I did a fundraiser for human trafficking victims.
This week I'm with the traffickers.
You guys were a lot more fun.
And they're clapping.
They're clean,
they love it.
They're leaning in to being good.
They're,
they're,
you know,
they're morally compromise.
Well,
there also hired a comedian to fuck with them.
Yes,
that's a good point.
I mean,
they expected,
it's not like that came out of nowhere.
Well,
you know,
I mean,
it's like,
so that's the thing.
It's like Trump bad,
but I don't know what the geospatial people are too.
I don't have to,
I don't want to throw my hat in with geospatial intelligence.
Yeah.
I don't know what that means.
I mean,
maybe we need it,
you know?
But listen again to standup comedians talking about what the world needs.
Yeah,
it's not great.
It's fucking terrible,
right?
I mean,
I've been trying to stress this more than ever because of the fact that I have a
microphone.
Right.
And people are listening.
Don't fucking pay attention to me.
Okay.
I am not right.
Well,
the best thing is,
listen,
you don't,
you don't know.
You might be right.
You're right.
But I'm definitely not an expert.
The best thing is if you go on Twitter and a comedian will tweet something
really,
you know,
it's like we're living in fascism and then again,
like 400,000 likes and then the next tweet,
have you ever seen this to go?
And while you guys are here,
check out my web series
and he'd go,
are we,
are we living in fat?
If we're living in fascism,
you too.
I have a web series.
You can't have a Webster's.
And do I have the time to luxuriate in your web series or should I start arming
myself?
Throw the gun?
What should I,
what should I look at my phone?
I'm like,
which way should I go?
But that's all they do.
They go by,
by the way,
while you're here,
I have a patriot.
We're doing a project.
I'd like you to throw a few bucks there,
but we're living in fascism and you know,
well the signal to noise ratio in terms of like people tweeting,
it's almost mostly noise.
Oh,
it's nice.
There's a few people that are great.
You could fall a few people that are really posting about real news.
And for some journalists,
17 of them,
I think journalists are maybe the best people to follow on Twitter right now it
seems like.
But the problem is who's a journalist?
There's very few real journalism takes a long time.
It's expensive.
Like real investigative journalism.
And I've had some of these guys,
my podcast,
they come on,
they go,
they've ruined their life.
They spend five years looking into something.
Nobody cares about it.
They figured out it was true.
And,
and nobody wants to talk to them.
They will have white hair.
They're families hate them.
They live in a little apartment in New York City.
That's a journalist.
Well,
sometimes people do journalism,
right,
and they,
they do spend a long time working on a project and it's in something like the
New York Times and no one cares.
No one cares.
Like the thing about Trump,
like the report on Trump,
this scathing report,
they thought it was going to bring them down.
Literally it was in and out of the news cycle on a day or two.
Yeah.
They don't care.
That guy just pops an extra Adderall and doesn't give up.
He doesn't care.
He doesn't give a fuck.
He is the only guy that should ever write a motivational HealthSouth hop
the secret.
Right.
Whenever the secret is,
he's got it.
I think it's speed.
It's speed.
You think he's really,
yeah.
Yeah,
I do.
Yeah.
I think it's speed.
I think he's on something.
I mean,
I think this is the only way that it makes sense to me that a 70 plus year old
man has that much energy.
A guy doesn't exercise,
eats fast food,
and he's fucking bouncing off the walls and he can campaign for days and days.
Just,
Ooh,
KFC,
double downs and flay a fishes.
And let me ask you this,
how often,
if he gets his dick sucked and question,
who's doing it?
Great question and not asked enough,
right?
Probably not that much.
I don't think a guy like that is driven by sex.
I don't get that.
Maybe he'd be,
but Milania seems to be not into it as much.
It seems a little upset with them.
She seems a bit cold,
but there she Slovenian or something,
something like that.
They're cold.
I don't know.
That's,
well that's some of the generalizations.
They're white,
so I can generally say what I want about them.
Ciao.
Okay.
Let me say what the Hell I want.
And Eastern Europeans.
Can I not have Slovenians you can.
Okay,
thank you.
Ah,
she's called.
Well,
she,
I think she's a little annoyed with them,
you know what I mean?
She was very humiliating for her.
They had the pest life.
Yeah.
Up until he ran for president.
He,
I mean,
imagine telling his kids,
he's like,
I know you got world billionaires,
you'll party every day.
You do coke with impunity.
It's some New York City nightclub.
When you boarded that,
you go to Europe,
do it on a boat when you bought it that you go to some origene Athens,
that's all done right.
But we're going to Canton,
Ohio and I'm giving a speech and you can stand there because,
and every camera,
every news reporter is going to watch every move you make the rest of your life
you're going to crawl up your ass with a microscope to and everyone hates you
and some of them might be going to jail.
I mean,
we don't,
we really don't know what's going on with this Mueller investigation.
And I think a lot,
I mean,
I think it's going to be disappointing.
Everybody's preparing anything for disappointment.
Everybody has prepared us for disappointment.
Yeah.
CNN is actually was saying that that don't expect much.
It's like when you get a report card and you'd tell your parents,
you're like,
no,
I've changed but I'm still me still know what I mean.
I'm still the guy who gets high before he goes into school and was caught
smoking by the priests.
Like I used to get caught smoking weed by the priest who driving it in my
Catholic school and he would drive me to the school.
So I would be like,
yeah,
I've made some changes,
but I'm still very much that person that you guys raised.
So that I think is what the Mueller report is going to be like Trump.
But the thing about Trump is he's corrupt.
He's a con man,
you know,
he said he had this whole wall that there was no wall.
Well,
this is not coming.
Little links,
the walls,
not in some wall.
There's no wall.
This is a little signs.
It's a finished the wall.
But this part,
this part of a wall,
there's more,
there's more of a wallet around houses in Belair,
right.
Then there is at the border.
But you know,
it's a smaller area,
a pillar.
It's,
yeah.
And there's probably more of a reason to have a wall,
you know,
and the people that run bel air or probably more serious.
Yeah,
yeah.
That's definitely something that,
you know,
I,
I don't know,
uh,
about this whole wall thing.
I really feel like it was one of those campaigns,
slogans that he got stuck with,
you know,
build that wall.
And then once he got in he was like,
oh Christ,
I really got to build this fucking thing.
It's his slogan,
someone whispered into his ear,
you think he and culture probably said,
get out there and say build the wall.
And he goes,
that's good.
And then you just went out there,
build that wall.
I love the,
one of the speeches,
he doesn't really build things.
He lent his name to be franchised.
Yeah,
he definitely does that.
He's not a bit like this idea that he's like a bit the things he's built or
disgusting.
If you go to Atlantic city,
what can any building he has built it is to,
Chris Hedges wrote a book,
he's an interesting guy.
He wrote a book called America,
the farewell tour and he goes,
he went,
he went to Trump tower in Atlantic city.
He goes,
there's junkies in the bathrooms,
does like rats running around is falling apart.
And he's like,
that's kind of what you know America will be,
but no anything he's built.
He's not nice.
Did you watch it?
There was a documentary about an architect called Costas carry on us and he had,
and a lot of the documentary is about him convincing Trump to not make his
building gold in New York City and I,
and it's like,
is it Golden New York City?
But it's Golden Vegas gold a lot of places.
But like he was going to ruin the,
the downtown of Manhattan with a gold building.
Why is that ruining it though?
A gold building.
Why not?
You've spent too much time on the west coast,
but why is that bad?
Why is it bad for it to be one car?
Is it better if it's all black or all white or silver?
It's a look.
It has a feel.
You can't come in with a gold building.
It's not Vegas.
It's not Atlantic city.
This is not right.
You know,
like Mandalay Bay,
what goes on in a gold building.
I've never looked at a gold building and said,
I bet what goes on there is honest,
like decent gold buildings should be for doing coke and losing money.
That's what it's about.
You don't walk in with a building and get a checkup.
That's good point.
Yeah.
That was a very good point.
Gaudy.
It's disgusting.
Yeah.
God,
he is a weird thing,
right?
Like who's that?
Who's that good for?
Like when you go to a place and it's got opulent Chandelier's guilded furniture,
sociopaths who sacrifice human beings.
That's the way they want to lift.
They want to live in a,
uh,
a palatial opulent environment.
And then just,
you know,
I think Matt,
he be,
he said this,
he said that Trump is a poor person's idea of a rich person.
Absolutely.
That's what a rich person thinks.
When a poor person thinks about a rich person,
they think,
oh,
he's got his name on his jet and he's got his name on his building.
And the guys I grew up with in long island,
if somebody went to them and said,
hey,
you could own the Miss Universe pageant.
You could have a building with your name on it.
You could be in the WWE,
that would be amazing.
You'd be a winner.
They would be a winner.
Where I grew up in long island,
that would be,
that is the highest you can go.
So I think that's kind of what it is.
It's a very,
what's,
see what's appealing.
That's also what's appealing about them.
What's appealing about him is there is no veneer,
right?
You don't get the idea that you're being played,
you get the idea,
you know you're kind of being played,
but you're being played on a level that you accept.
It's like when you go buy a car and you know the salesman,
I used to be in sales,
so like when I'll go to buy something,
sometimes I know the salesman needs the sale because I used to.
So like sometimes it'd be like,
yeah,
whatever it is what it is,
you know,
I just,
I'll do it.
That's kind of with Trump,
you know you're being sold,
but you're okay with it.
You let it happen.
What do you think is going to come after him?
It seems like he's throwing a giant monkey wrench into the gears.
Twitter is any indication,
a prolonged civil conflict,
uh,
where there will be,
where some will emerge as a few different nation.
States will barter with each other.
Um,
I don't know,
maybe Joe Biden and then nothing.
He's got no chance.
He's,
he's who do you,
who's coming.
She's got no chance.
Bernie.
They hate now.
They hate me.
Know a lot of people hate Bernie.
What happened?
I don't know it,
some kind of staff was accused of sexual assault.
Oh,
and now they hate burning.
He's a rapist.
Well,
that's,
you know,
that's what happens.
Bernie's,
he's a white,
straight male.
He doesn't get it.
Plus he has like two houses.
He's worth like $300,000.
You know,
that offends people.
Yeah.
How'd you get that money off the backs of poor people in a country,
by the way,
where people make that a in and hour on youtube.
You know,
some people do
Logan,
Paul and all those guys.
Those guys,
you know,
you see people in la.
I'll see a kid in la on a skateboard.
I'm like,
he's a millionaire.
He owns three houses because he used youtube live streamer.
Yeah.
He's probably playing video games on twitch.
Everything my parents told me to do go to school.
That implies impoverished my generation,
everything they told us not to do,
which is play video games,
watch TV,
get high is making people billionaires.
It's amazing.
Yeah,
they were wrong.
They were definitely wrong.
Boomers were wrong about everything.
Well they didn't see this coming.
They didn't see this craziness come in and see any of that come in.
You know what concerns me is,
uh,
the rise of people that think that everyone owes them something.
Sure.
You know,
that's,
that's the door.
That's the weird one.
Like we were talking about AOC who,
you know,
said she seems like a nice girls cause looking woman.
She's young,
she's got energy,
she wants to do good things.
She wants to do some good ones.
But I saw the one thing that said give money to people who are unable or
unwilling to work.
Yeah.
That's,
I saw that and I'm like,
I'm going to work.
Well it's not,
and they pulled that out.
They pulled that part out.
The unwilling park in her unable to work makes total sense.
You know,
we,
we as a community,
we should take care of the people.
Most of the people that are now in comedy or unable to work,
most of us,
yes.
This is the only thing we can do.
But her thing was a weird one because that,
that thing,
unwilling to work.
It's like,
hey,
hey.
He just,
he just crossed over into crazy town like this is,
but that means that crazy town was always in the back.
You always had that.
Yeah.
When you put that on paper,
that means this is something that's been discussed,
like part of the appeal and she just,
I don't know how influential she wasn't getting Amazon to drop out in New York,
but I live in Queens,
so everyone is paranoid.
Amazon was coming,
was a Bagel.
I,
no carbs,
no good.
But I was in a Bagel shop.
I gave up dairy two weeks ago.
I'm turning it around,
trying to get around.
I was in a Bagel shop.
It was paranoid about Amazon.
Amazon is going to come.
We're all going to get priced out of my little shoebox is it we live in or the,
some of the people that own those shoe boxes were like,
I'm a millionaire now because Amazon's coming and the,
but here's the thing,
it's hard to have a rational discussion about a co inequality right now because
in a place like New York City,
it's so expensive to live and the reason for that is that it's a destination for
foreign capital.
So essentially a lot of the buildings in New York City,
foreign people buy apartments.
They don't live in them.
They use it to like launder money and they buy them not even under their real
name.
They buy them under the name of a Shell Corp like an LLC and then they have like
these investments and it,
it really makes everything insanely expensive.
That's what's making everything.
That's what's making a lot of real estate in New York City.
Expensive.
What do you what like what if you got to guess what percentage of like expensive
apartments are owned by?
I'll tell you,
between 2008 and 2014 I think 50% of apartments going into contract were cause I
do a shell,
but I,
I used to be a double decker tour guide in New York City and so I do a show,
like a funny comedy show where I take,
I sell tickets,
I put people on a tour bus and then we'd go around to these building,
just scream at these buildings.
It's fun.
It should be illegal,
but it's fun and,
and no one cares because they're not home because there somewhere,
I mean it feeling,
if you look at who owns these buildings,
just a guy who like is maybe a guy who owns a mining company and he poisoned to
river in Zambia.
The a lot of these guys are doing things they shouldn't be doing and they want
to stash their money in real estate.
London is insane.
It's more expensive than New York because London is all essentially shell
corporations.
You know these phantom buyers buying up real estate in London,
in New York.
So you have people in New York that know the system is fucked.
They know the markets being artificially manipulated.
Bloomberg thought it was great.
Bloomberg is,
we want all of the billionaires.
He said it,
that was his quote.
We want all the bay.
It's like some of those billionaires have done things that would make you would
keep you up at night.
They've,
you know,
numbers like bring them in,
they eat shrimp and steak,
they'll go to Peter Luger's.
We love him as a businessman.
Right?
That's a thing.
So people get fed up with death and dude,
and when I was,
had my tour bus,
people would get on from regular places like Pennsylvania now just point and go
10 million,
20 million,
30 minute.
And these people just shift uncomfortably in their seats.
Like what the Hell is going on here?
This is the,
you know,
I saw Trump getting elected during those tours because I'm like $100 million and
they're like sitting there like,
what?
I can't afford a knee operation.
Well,
the idea that Trump's not a part of that as he increases,
listen in his bit,
his building was a huge destination.
Russians love his building.
They love it.
They love a brand name.
They love the plaza.
They love his building,
and a lot of interesting characters lived in Trump tower.
Didn't they take the Trump tower name off of it in New York?
Yeah.
Wasn't,
no,
I don't want to else.
There was one of the buildings where the people that own the co op decided to
take the name off of it.
Maybe there's another,
there's a lot of shitty like Trump nursing homes too,
as I've been in New York.
Oh yes.
Nursing homes,
you know those elderly people getting beaten.
It's hard to say
Joe.
You know,
they're getting fleeced.
The beaten.
You go by,
you see like Trump pavilion.
It's like a Soviet era architecture.
Horrible like old age home that's been there since the 70s and I'm like,
man,
I feel for the people in there,
the screams,
it must other New York condo votes to remove Trump from name.
Yeah,
New York City condominium.
On Thursday,
we removed president Trump's name from the buildings facade.
The second time at four months,
his name has been removed from a condo in the city.
55% of Trump plays condo owners at 120 Riverside Boulevard in Manhattan.
Voted in favor of removing the large sign above the front door,
the buildings.
I mean that crazy.
Who Cares?
These are self important people,
but when care is,
they're worried about their,
their secure attachment.
Oh,
that's a good point.
Yeah.
I think if you try to sell it and it's Trump place and you know you're going to
eliminate 50% of your buyers dictators that are buying those apartments,
I think it's great.
They die.
Maybe they don't.
Maybe they're like,
you know,
probably we'll probably go down the street to this no name building.
We'll be better off.
But a lot of his condos were sold to,
you know,
Mafia and you know,
Russian business guys and he's always hide that,
you know,
he did deals.
It was his firm located in Trump tower called Bay rock financial,
which was a,
it was headed by this guy,
Felix Sader.
Felix Sater was a guy who the FBI,
uh,
convicted in like a Russian pump and dumps stock scam.
And he worked in Trump tower with Trump.
Like he worked very closely with Trump and Felix had like informed,
I think on the Russian mob for the feds and the feds kind of let him earn.
And so Trump has had this labyrinth of shady connections forever.
Wow.
And I don't know if that means that he's ness.
I don't think he's an asset or of Putin or anything like that.
I don't believe that.
I think that's kind of just,
you know,
I think it's,
a lot of people would like to believe that,
but he's a shady guy.
So if you have all these people pouring over his business deals for the last 50
years,
it can't be good.
There could be an amazing movie about him.
Oh,
there will be.
And who would play him?
Ah,
good question.
Hopefully not a white man.
Christian Bale.
Uh,
let them get fat.
Just like he did with Dick Cheney.
We played Dick.
If he could play Dick Cheney,
he can do Trump.
He can put a truck.
He was a great Cheney.
I thought I heard.
I haven't seen him yet.
I heard it was amazing.
I,
you know the movie with like a lot of people,
the movie was good.
It was not,
you know,
it's like the big short to me was amazing.
I don't think it was as good as that,
but Christian Bale is phenomenal.
He's a phenomenal act.
I mean,
to gain that much weight,
to become another person.
That's all thing with Jesse Small.
It's like they're all,
all these actors are sociopaths.
They're all sociopaths.
Watches Good Morning America interview and try not to laugh.
Well now it's,
it's crazy what he said.
He's the gay Tupac like
85 back and great.
Those guys like,
oh my God,
crisis PR firm is telling him to do that.
The Gay Tupac,
no one's telling them to do that.
This is all so this is Bridget Fetisi said it best.
She says she's hilarious.
She said,
this is what happens when you let actors write the script.
Well,
that's true.
See the plot twist coming a mile away.
I had dinner the other night.
I was in La and an act was at the table and he was talking and I'm like,
I don't know who this guy is,
but he's not even the person he is at this table.
Right,
right.
He's trying out a person right now.
Have you ever been in that situation?
I don't know who he is,
but he's not this guy.
He doesn't know who he is either.
He says no clue.
It's just good looking guy that vapid.
He's full of nothing.
He wants to get famous asap and they say things.
Oh yeah.
Other people are saying,
here's one good to see you.
Yes.
When they meet you,
they say,
good to see you because they might have met you and they don't want to forget
100% so I've said that before.
Nice to me and they're like,
actually we met before.
I'm like fuck.
They'll ask in a very strange way,
they'll be like,
what's going on?
Like what's up?
What's going on?
Like you want it,
they want it.
You want,
they want you,
they want to be fed.
They want to be fed information.
Yeah.
It's like what's going on?
And I'm like,
wow,
you know,
a lot of projects.
He Shit Bro,
guest spotted flappers Ah,
lots of things happening and uh,
cause you're always trying to move.
That's the thing about La New York is just pound yourself into the ground until
you get funny.
That's kind of what the New York scene,
the New York scene is like two 57 shows a day.
Give up on your life,
don't speak to your family,
they're losers are holding it back.
Go hard.
La is like make a friend,
have lunch,
see what happens.
I talked to some of the people out here and I'm like,
what's the plan?
I get nervous for them.
I'm like,
they're getting high.
It's mid day.
I'm like,
okay,
it's Wednesday too.
They're like,
we just had a meeting.
I'm like,
what'd you do?
They go,
we're talking about starting a podcast.
I'm like,
that's not a meeting.
You're just friends with someone else.
You're talking about stuff that's nothing.
But here's the thing,
it does work here and there are people that I know who've made the right friend
and then their life changes.
Yeah,
there's a little of that.
But those people were super transparent and if you don't have any talent that's
never going to never work.
And then everybody resents you.
There's a few of those people that really don't have any talent,
but they made the right friends and they cling on to folks and everybody gets
real uncomfortable.
And that was thing,
I think the first time we spoke is I've written,
I think about Louis and after Louise and the whole news,
but Louie happened,
you had all this love that piece by the accurate an honest,
yeah,
it was on Facebook,
which where I did a lot of my best work.
Blame what you were saying.
[inaudible] didn't read it after Louis.
A lot of people were rightly criticized and conduct and you know the whole me
too thing.
That's all valid in short.
100% needs to happen.
But then there were people that were like,
you know,
Louie was never funny or Louie was just,
of course he got all these things.
He was a white guy or,
and I'm like,
wait,
what?
And they were like,
well,
he said this word I don't like.
Well look at this joke and I'm like,
guys,
a week ago he was a comic genius.
We all agreed on that.
That was a widely held belief.
Now out of nowhere,
he's not that funny.
And,
and these people are tweeting this from parking lots where they're performing
some of these shows in la or in like someone's driveway,
you know,
and which is fine.
I do them,
I've no problem with that.
But they're getting on Twitter and,
and knocking Louis from the back of a parking lot where they're doing a show.
But what the reason you gave for why,
well,
because these,
there's,
in any industry,
people are going to get ahead by being agreeable,
by having the right opinions,
by crowd sourcing their opinions,
by taking the temperature of the room and going,
how does everyone feel?
And those people are,
you know,
they're careerists are very good at office politics.
They're very good at having the right friends,
but their contributions are never really important,
are long lasting because they never get great because they don't take any risk.
Because I think greatness is something you have to risk constantly to get to
that level.
So a lot of these people do very well.
They make money,
they're,
they're successful,
but they are careerist and they're looking for comfort.
And so when it was comfortable and safe to attack Louie and to bring Louie down
and to elevate themselves,
they did it.
But they didn't do it when it could have hurt their career a week earlier,
you know?
So to me it was very disingenuous and the fact that more people weren't calling
it out.
And,
and I,
and I made that point where I said the same thing on the other side of people
who styled themselves.
Like I'm a free speech warrior.
I'm this anti PC in their whole entire persona is,
is that the need to say the n word?
They're like,
I can't do a joke if the punchline isn't fact.
Like they're like,
we have to.
So those to me are kind of the same
people and they're the people that are just trying to arrange the world in a way
that allows them to succeed.
Those are the types of people.
Also like you were talking about the actor in the retail,
you mean they're,
they're putting on a facade,
not who they've adopted a predetermined pattern or behavior.
100% that predetermined pattern of behavior might be,
I'm a guy I drink every night.
We go hard,
right?
I'm an artist,
I smoked cigarettes,
I don't give a fuck.
No,
I'm not trying to get on TV.
Yeah.
So to me it was like incredibly disingenuous.
He had all these people and a lot of them are angry and they're doing fine.
Like some of them were talent.
Like some of these people have their own shows and they're getting angry at
Louie and angry and I'm like there's,
there's a real,
because here's the thing,
Ari Shaffir told me something that made a lot of sense once he goes,
it's,
it can really be a waste to get into this type of business and end up in an
office writing for a show you don't care about in a job you hate punching a
clock.
And that stuck with me and always take,
it might be harder to go the other way and to build a fan base and to do what
you want,
but it's going to be,
it's going to be better in the end and you're not going to be angry.
You're not going to be resentful.
And I think a lot of the people that were were again shitting on his comedy,
not so much his behavior,
but it's comedy are people that are,
would want more in this than they have.
And they're resentful at guys like Louie because it,
it's not fair how talented he is.
Well,
it's not just how talented he is,
his work ethic,
there's a lot of the factors,
the risks that he does take.
I mean,
he,
he says controversial things.
He always has.
Whether you agree or not.
Like one of the things about the Parkland thing,
you know,
and when he got in trouble about,
uh,
you know,
saying that all you did was put some fat kid out of the way.
Yeah.
That is so consistent with his material.
The idea that anybody's saying like,
oh my God,
he's punching down.
Like you need to go review his material again because he said a lot of risky
shit because it was funny and he had really good points about it.
Yeah.
Is that something that I would joke about?
Probably not.
Right,
but he did.
He wouldn't joke about fat people.
Uh,
yes I would,
but I don't think I would joke about kids getting shot.
It's a tough take.
Yeah.
To make funny,
but that's right.
Yeah.
But I think he could.
I think honestly we were,
you're dealing with,
first of all,
the embryo of a bit.
I mean he's really only been doing standup again for a couple of months in
Pakistan.
It was even less.
And I think ultimately his idea that bed is that bit rather is that kids today,
like they want to be a VA and have them when they have a 78 different genders.
And why am I,
why are you interesting?
You're interesting because you didn't get shot.
That is his take on it.
And he probably with overall reaction and anticipation of reaction probably
would have eliminated that part of the bit.
Sure.
And you know what I'm saying?
Like you know how it works.
I'm still shocked.
I think part of it is too,
I was attracted to comedy because of guys like Bill Hicks or Patricia people
that can pick the things that those guys said.
You could only say on a stage if you were really funny.
Right.
That's what I love about common.
Me Too.
That doesn't mean that everyone has to love that.
There is people that love it for a million different reasons.
Sure.
But I love when Bill Hicks got up and he said I was for the war,
but against the troops.
That's still,
to me,
one of the most amazing jokes I've ever heard when he goes,
we had a war in the states.
I was in the unenviable position of being for the war,
but against the trip,
it's like all those men living together.
Yeah.
I just don't like young people or whatever.
He fight.
It's just great.
I'm like,
Oh,
you couldn't say that in a human resources May.
You couldn't say that in an office.
Right.
He couldn't say that.
If you were out to lunch with a bunch of people,
probably couldn't get away with that unless you were really funny.
But these guys have gotten so funny and they've,
you know,
perfected their craft to the point where they can get away with these things
that the goal is to elicit laughter.
It's not really,
you're not going to change your mind,
but the goal is to make you laugh about something that's dark and horrible.
That's what I love about calm.
Yeah.
It's some of my favorite material.
Some of my favorite material is fucked up.
It's wrong.
You probably shouldn't have said it would make me Howell out.
Have you seen Holtzman?
No.
You never seen Brian Holtzman?
Oh my God.
Like store.
Yeah.
You should check them out.
How long are you in town for?
I'm a temporal of widely early March for wedding.
Oh,
I'll call him back like a week.
A month now.
Well,
he'll be here.
I'm sure he's here either Friday or Saturday cause he doesn't really do the
road.
He mostly just does the store.
Yeah,
I don't even think he does other clubs.
I think I lost as a story when I started in 94.
He was coming up.
He was there at the store in [inaudible] 94.
Wow.
And uh,
he was already there when I got there and I was like,
Whoa,
this guy is going to be huge.
And for whatever reason,
he never left.
He just does the store.
But he's a legend,
but it's the best room.
I mean,
I just did a few guest spots here and I'm like,
oh,
this is the best room in the cut.
Like I wouldn't leave.
I'm like,
this is amazing.
Yeah,
but you gotta leave.
Like I'm doing the Improv tonight or what?
I did the Improv the other night.
I'm doing the Improv tomorrow and I mix it up and I did the ice house last
night.
Right.
I mix it up.
You got,
I think you have to,
but it's the best room in the world.
Is he one of those guys who does this stuff where you're like,
I can't believe I'm laughing.
When Susan Smith drown her kids.
Remember that he got gauge that night.
He's like laser gentlemen heard.
Those were bad kids.
I heard they sat that closer to TV.
They never put away their blocks.
They're constantly spelt the fucking milk.
Those kids would not be missed.
It's all A's.
I was like,
Jesus Christ.
Wow.
Mitzi shore would not let him go onstage after nine 11 she would not let him go
and she told me because she was like,
you were on the bench and how long?
Like weeks.
Oh my God.
He got,
she's like,
don't let him on.
He got benched after nine 11 by Mitzi shore.
That's great.
Sure.
Let you get away with fucking anything.
That's a while now.
And this is pre social media too.
She wasn't worried about a tweet storm.
No.
No,
you can't.
It can't let him up.
I love pre-twitter to not let someone up.
It has to be so gracious.
He's a fucking animal man.
It's,
he's so funny.
He's so far the things you laughed the heart,
you know when you're,
I was looking at it as like when I was going through a Taco bell drive through
in 11th grade and we were all stoned.
The things you would make jokes,
nobody in the car would ever go.
That's too much.
If they did get rid of them,
they're done.
They,
you know,
no one means that.
No,
we would let each other's families.
You,
my mother's just gets a phrenic.
We would make fun of my mother,
you know,
and it,
it was great.
Yeah,
I still do.
Yeah.
If you're someone in your family's mental wheel,
you're not making fun of them.
Your,
it's your problem because difference is between east coast and west coast
comedy.
Is it west coast comedy?
They hold that carrot of a Sitcom or uh,
you know,
hosting the tonight show or something like that above your head.
We had health insurance always there.
East Coast comedy is just be funny,
be funny till you die and be funny and mean.
There's a lot of meanness and there's a lot of holes in the winter.
It's cold and mean.
And that's really,
you know,
it's real.
But you know what I like about west coast coming to choose,
it's a lot of performing cause he's,
the rooms are big.
Yeah.
And use your big east coast rooms are a little smaller.
She have a lot of like writers.
I love the performing style so I kind of like seeing people in the store with
big acts.
Yeah.
There's not a lot of room to move.
Like if you're at the stand or the seller,
something you are a little small.
Yeah,
they're tight little rooms.
You can't use [inaudible] on stage performers in those rooms that rock out in
the stroller.
But like when I was in the store I was like oh there's huge rooms.
Big performers and that's awesome.
Especially like the main room,
the main room is amazing.
Giant stage.
Yeah,
it is interesting.
I like those really small intimate rooms in New York.
They lend themselves a lot to talking to the crowd and being sharp and having
really sharp bits that hit.
And then I think,
and that's why you get to go everywhere because you need the,
when you go on the road,
you want to,
you want a little bit of everything,
you want to be able to perform and you want to have sharp jokes,
but you gotta be able to do crowd work.
You've got to,
you know,
yeah.
I started on Boston and Boston was always,
no one has a long attention span.
Everybody wants to do the jokes quick and if you start bombing,
you're not going to recover.
Really.
Nobody recovers in Boston.
It's tough out there.
And once you start eating shit they've done with Bobby,
Kelly would tell me stories about like the rooms he came up to him.
They are rough rooms.
Yeah.
We came up together.
I mean I did a lot of road gigs go.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
We actually lose that.
Like what area of boss is that?
Like outside of Boston?
Yeah,
we did a lot of the Dick Dardy comedy huts.
Okay.
Out in the middle of fucking nowhere.
Sounds great to Worcester.
Other were great.
There were [inaudible] which is like a Polynesian restaurant.
Yeah.
And they would have comedy hut.
I went,
I did it.
I did one the 50 minutes Netflix specials.
I went the next day to two days later I went to a room in Massachusetts outside
of Boston and I bombed so bad.
It was amazing.
I was like,
well this is why the funniest people in the world come from this state.
Where was it?
Where was I?
I forget it was a,
um,
I don't want to say the actual show who did bucket.
This guy booked and he knows exactly.
He would probably tweet me or something.
But it was in God,
it was outside.
It was like 20 minutes outside.
It was in,
it was in,
I'm not Hingham,
but it was,
it was somewhere and it was not good.
It was just a bar.
It was a circular bar and I got up and then nobody was like w in the middle of
my set of woman to Trump,
woman started yelling me and then I yell back at her and then it was okay cause
we yelled at each other for 20 minutes.
That was just show.
What did she yell?
I think it was something you have that funny.
If fat fucks up something that was justified at that moment in the set.
I went back at her,
I was like,
listen to me,
you fucking animal.
And then it was great.
And then they,
they perked right up and then the material worked after that.
It's always exciting when something like that happens.
It's like finally that was,
it was the Trump moment,
this moment where people are like sat up in their chair and they're like,
okay,
we can,
you know,
um,
when I was living in Boston,
you could make a living and not leave.
Oh Wow.
You could stay in Boston and you could go 20 minutes here,
30 minutes there.
You go to Andover,
you go to hang them,
you go to Framingham who go to all these different places and you got two gigs
and I mean you wouldn't get rich,
but you could pay your bills and never leave town.
And so there was so much comedy.
There was so many rooms.
Like Barry Katz had a bunch of rooms and the common connection had a bunch of
rooms and Mike Clarke had a bunch of rooms and there were slower.
That's what really got you really strong.
Yeah.
Because you're mostly doing these hell gigs during these hell gigs everywhere.
And so when I came to New York,
what got me was that everything was like small.
There were small crowds,
small stages,
and you would do a short amount of time.
Yeah.
And I was like,
Ooh,
I don't like this that much.
I could showcase set like 1510 15 minutes.
Yeah.
Because I was doing like middle sets.
I do a half hour and then I,
I was headline and I do 45 minutes.
Well,
so come out to long island.
We have kind of,
it's an approximation,
you know,
of a Boston,
they're wild folks.
Oh,
I did a lot of gigs in row on long island.
A lot of gigs along.
They'll tell you the benefit of the doubt is nonexistent.
Yeah.
When I got out there,
east side comedy club was there.
Oh Wow.
That was back in the day when Jenny was still around.
I remember,
I tell this story all the time,
but it's so crazy.
Like people forgot how God damn good.
Richard Jenny was,
he was there one night.
He did four different hours on Friday and Saturday.
So he did two shows Friday,
two show,
Saturday four completely different hours.
And the,
the,
the opening act and the this,
uh,
what the fuck was it?
How the fuck was the,
uh,
the MC was a friend of mine,
Peter.
God,
it,
Peter Boyle.
Peep your pill.
I forget his last name.
Peter Bales.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I know acid is a good dude.
older guy.
Younger.
Back then this was back in the Disney,
but he was just like shaking his head like,
what the fuck man?
The guy did for different hours.
Yeah.
And I remember,
you know,
I was just barely starting out and I was sitting back on what the fuck,
how does a man do for different hours?
He goes,
he didn't repeat a premise.
He did repeat a punchline.
He did.
And he crushed.
And this is one weekend,
one weekend,
two shows,
Friday two shows.
Saturday.
He was a genius man.
He was responsible for so many people's acts two he would tighten up people.
He worked a lot with rock.
Yeah.
Work with a lot with Chris on the road and,
and worked on.
Helped them with a specials.
Was He from Boston,
Jenny or was he was in New York guy.
Okay.
Yeah.
I think he was from Brooklyn.
He was fucking amazing man.
But that was the east side comedy club back in the day.
Yeah.
No,
it's good.
Those rooms,
like governors of brokerage.
I liked those rooms because you,
you go out there and if you're funny,
you're funny,
you'll kill.
And if you're,
if you're like lacking or I feel like a bit half done to let you know,
they'll let you know.
Yeah.
They paid the money to let you know.
Ah,
you'll hear it audibly,
but that's good.
You need that.
Like Holly Quinn builds,
he shows there and it,
they're amazing because,
and there,
you know,
his new shows,
great red state,
blue state.
But like did he filled it out there?
I don't know if he did this one be built a lot of his shows out there because
like he goes out there and he says if it's good,
they're really going to let you know.
So it's where a lot of comics will go and test.
Similar to the reloads rooms in Boston,
you really test,
you get coddled a little bit.
In New York City.
In La you get cuddles.
Who'd got to go out there to somebody who doesn't give a shit?
That's,
you know,
the people who were like,
listen,
I'm either those people out there don't choose to laugh.
They laugh or they don't.
Right.
You got to echo park.
They choose.
Yeah.
They sit there and they go,
ah.
Or they'll go like this and go,
no,
look in their face you'll see it.
They'll be like,
no.
Out in those areas like [inaudible].
It's an instinctual,
guttural laugh.
Yeah,
it's not,
it's,
it's not the,
yeah.
The thing about like laughter when you're choosing to laugh,
he in here and there,
it's so pretentious.
It's not fun.
Yeah.
It goes back to that example of like growing up you,
you're making people laugh.
Who the hell's choosing to laugh?
What psychopath is sitting there going?
Ah.
Also they're mostly in the business.
Like a lot of the audiences in the business,
the whole thing is to this weird entire thing is agents who are like 22 years
old.
Yep.
They're like embryos to so young.
The agents and agents and managers for the most part,
excluding mine who I love by agents and managers,
they're rich kids who can't do tech or finance.
Let's be a lot of them.
There's quite a few,
let's be honest,
he's a rich kid whose parents go,
hey,
can you do something because I don't want to look at you anymore and they're not
going to get a job at jolly bee.
Right?
So they're going to go get a desk at UTA or CAA or WME and most,
I mean,
everyone needs one too.
That's the other big thing.
Like you're not going to negotiate on your own.
You're going to do a terrible job.
If you negotiate your own gigs.
I will take any amount of money to do anything.
I mean,
I'm horrible at negotiating.
I was bad in sales,
sales didn't work.
And now I'm here.
You know,
apparently
Bill Murray doesn't have an agent or a manager.
He has an answering machine and people call them up and they make them offers to
do things and he'll like listen to those messages and go,
hmm,
I'll do that one.
And he just goes and does it.
Well,
if you're like a legend like that,
yeah,
I guess you can do that and you can do whatever he wants.
What an interesting says.
No,
I need an agent like blackmail,
paypal,
CIA level,
blackmail to get me into rooms.
Well the thing is,
it's not just that,
like you need someone to actually do the talking for you to like get gigs.
Oh yeah.
Or you know,
to negotiate your money or to do your air travel.
It's not call me and she'll be like,
they wanted 85 shows over the weekend.
I got a dentist,
you know,
cause I'm looking at newer comics so if they want nine,
seven shows,
I do it.
Y'All do it.
Do you get when you five shows on Saturday,
I'll do it two or three shows on Saturday night.
Yeah.
Three at the same clubs sometimes.
Those are weird.
That third show,
you don't know what the fuck you already shows.
Not even comedy anymore.
I don't know what is happening.
I don't know what's happening at that point.
But um,
it can be really foot.
The third show a lot of times is people,
the audience is people who have been asked to leave other venues,
so their trunk and walking by the club Nigga and that you're just,
their friend brings him in.
This is literally,
I've heard,
I've literally spoke to somebody,
I'm like,
why are they here?
And they were gone.
Well we were asked to leave and they saw it and they just saw the lights and
they like lights.
So we brought them in and now you're talking about,
you know,
frozen yogurt or whatever and they're,
if it's nuts,
what's the show's crazy.
What's the latest set you can get in New York City these days?
Oh,
you can get like,
I think it's like a two 45 or something.
You can get something crazy.
45 maybe it's two 30 maybe it's till you can get something really late.
Wow.
People are up.
Who the fuck is there to 45 there's people.
Really?
Yeah.
What's it like?
It ain't,
I mean I think it,
I think it's pretty good depending on the night,
like a Saturday night to 45 probably.
Great.
Why don't you listen or it gets,
yeah,
I think the seller is the latest.
I think you can get,
but as it gets louder,
I mean as it gets later,
people get drunker.
I used to do danger fields that's in there.
Yeah.
And we do prom shows.
Do you ever do the prom show thing?
I'm not a prompt show act.
This is what they do with a bunch of kids are sitting there and I walk out on
stage.
It's a bad prom.
Well,
it's always a bad prom.
Prom shows a terrible,
but what they do is they,
they don't,
and back in the day at least,
they didn't change the crowd.
So you would,
you would go out,
like say if there's like four comics on the light up,
there's an MC and three other comics and then there's the next show,
it starts all over again.
We see the same three comics,
the audiences there.
So they want you to do the exact same acts so that the kids will leave because
they have no account of the kids.
So that buses pulled up and they're just stuffing these kids in there and
they're hoping that if you do the same bits,
the kids will get bored.
And they got mad at me cause I'm like,
look,
I'm not doing the same material.
I see the same faces.
It's boring.
Yeah.
I'm only doing a 15 minutes set.
I go,
I have more material,
I'm going to do other,
other bits.
And they're like,
you got to do the same jokes.
We're trying to get these people out of here.
I'm like,
how about just the cast?
Just grab him.
Just get him Outta here.
Yeah,
just light a fire.
But we would do them til five o'clock in the morning.
Dangerfield,
the last time was in danger fields.
It was four people in a room,
two couples,
waiters about in his mid eighties.
I,
it's dark and I'm performing in front of a piano.
It's one of those nights where you go,
you know,
this was a choice I made to get into this business.
Um,
but there's something haunting about that room and it was actually fun.
I'm just entertaining to couples.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
I did one cup of once at the end.
Your fields,
there was no one,
there was no show.
I had a nine o'clock spot,
isn't it?
There's never a show.
I had a nine o'clock spot.
Yeah,
I got there at eight 45.
The comics are sitting around the bar.
I go,
what's going on?
They're like,
there's no one here.
I go,
And then right when I said that,
this couple walked up and Bobby,
who was the,
uh,
the doorman,
there's this fucking Scottish power lifter guy.
He was like five foot 10 and five foot 10 wide.
Oh,
interesting.
I saw him grab a kid by his neck at one of these prompts shows and pick him up
by his neck and carry them out of their cheese.
Anyway,
he was this tank of a man.
He was always fucking hilarious and ruthless on the comedians.
Yeah,
yeah.
You got to try that bag of Shite.
You call it a fucking act.
And,
and anyway,
these people walk in and he's like,
ladies,
gentlemen,
welcome to danger fields.
Come on right in.
And he brings him in and these people walked into his empty room and sit down
and they're like,
what the fuck is going on?
Like it crazy.
And then all of a sudden the lights come on and then the MC comes out and they
sat through all of us.
Wow.
Sat through.
I was like,
you know,
fourth on the lineup or something like that.
I did my fucking 15 minutes in front of these two people and they were into it.
They were great.
Yeah,
they were great,
but it was weird.
You know,
it's the,
those shows what's good about those shows build you?
Well,
they may,
they let you know what's bullshit and your act because you feel embarrassed
saying it.
That's a great point.
Yeah.
You feel it feels clunky coming out of your mouth,
right.
Especially to three people.
Well,
there's always,
things are always clunky,
right?
Like,
and when it's a small crowd,
they're really clunky.
Like when you're working on material,
every time I have a premise,
or even if I'm fucking telling a story,
a lot of times,
like as I'm starting to tell the story,
like the beginning part is a little fucking clunky and maybe I'm saying
something the wrong way and it doesn't make total sense.
And then eventually it catches on.
If you do that in front of two people,
they're like,
what are you doing?
Yeah.
The best story about the age of fields was there was a guy who walked in once I
was hitting in the bar area,
he had a Rodney Dangerfield,
a doll,
and he walked in.
He goes,
listen,
I've had a business for t,
you know,
for 10 years up the block I,
we found the stall.
I'm moving to,
you know,
wherever he was going.
He's like,
we're closing up shop.
Here you go.
I thought you might like it.
And then the guy took it,
he said to the owner,
he said he just,
there was no speaking right.
He just showed him this doll and then the owner just pointed and then the guy
carried this Rodney Dangerfield doll down the stairs and just put it in like
storage.
And it was the darkest moment,
which is such a dark moment to sit there silent.
Just the owner went and pointed in.
The guy just took this Dangerfield doll and he walked it down into caught,
only know the phantom of the opera,
whatever the hell goes down under that club.
But yeah,
that's a real,
that's like the oldest club in the country.
How's it still open?
I,
that is a great question that the FBI would probably want to look into.
I don't know
cause everybody's getting the same story.
People who was there,
people go 25 years ago,
25 years ago.
There was no one there.
I mean the fucking show that I'm telling you about,
that was 25 years ago.
There's never been anyone there.
I don't know.
Money off those prompts shows though.
They were packed.
It's like a great joke about like Nanette that my buddy nick Mullane is an
amazingly funny comedian,
said he's like in the net.
No one's seen,
it's just a trailer like no one seemed to net.
It's just a trailer and everyone's like,
it's brave.
It's really amazing.
It's my number one.
It's just a trailer.
It literally doesn't exist,
so maybe,
I don't know,
but it is.
It's one of those rooms in New York that's kind of haunting.
Yeah,
it's a strange place.
It did.
You ever listen to the day the laughter died?
No.
Dice Clay's a double album that he filmed there with no audience.
No one knew he was coming.
He had no material.
Zero.
That's amazing.
He just started talking about shit and ad libbing things and he was as big as a
fucking comedian could be at the time and he called it the day the laughter
died.
Right.
Ruben produced it.
That's no,
I've heard of it,
but I didn't know it was fucking brilliant and horrible at the same time.
Really.
Some guy gets up in the middle of his set,
he goes,
you're about as funny as our gloss or milk.
Oh my God.
What a polite apple.
What an old fashioned heckle.
I've never heard that.
Usually people are like,
shut up faggot.
You're a baptist.
Funny as a glass of milk.
It's lovely.
Yeah.
Some guy from Connecticut or something like that,
you know?
Then he got mad.
He got mad at dice and you know,
it's just shitting on him and shit on everything.
That's probably just destroyed it.
Well was it was destroying them,
but I'm telling you,
he wasn't even trying.
It was,
it was like he was at some crazy place in his career where he just decided to do
a set or he's bombing.
Do you ever think of doing something like that?
Crazy.
Never think it just called crazy into it.
Something completely.
I'm just trying to do,
first of all,
I would feel bad.
I can't do something bad on purpose because then people,
if I do something bad,
like if you,
ladies and gentlemen,
if you hear it and it sucks,
I fucked up.
That's it.
I've made it.
I made a mistake.
I didn't do it good.
Right.
I didn't,
uh,
didn't put it together.
Right.
A,
it's trial and error.
Sometimes it's an error.
I'm not going to do anything bad on purpose,
but he was so big and no one had been that big before.
Right.
Have to realize no one had done arenas before him.
He was the first arena caught first.
Yeah,
the first.
Yeah.
And a fucking hundred of them.
He would do them all over the country and he just had had enough for whatever
reason of fucking everybody loving him.
Yeah.
And he's like,
fuck you just went out and just said fucking double CD.
It's grey wt Broadway show,
like a live album recording of a Broadway show.
Hours of no material.
Just rambling,
talking about stuff,
punch lines that don't make sense.
He's just out there,
do whatever you want can great.
To this day,
it's one of my favorite comedy albums of all time.
I'll listen to it every now and then for like 15 minutes in my car,
I just go,
what the fat to me.
Is it all at Dangerfield?
Yes.
All of that.
All that danger fields.
No one knew he was coming.
Yeah.
And when they saw him,
they're like,
holy shit,
it's dice clay.
It was probably 20 people in the crowd who were so excited.
They probably did it on a Tuesday or some shit.
He's an animal.
That's amazing though.
Yeah,
that's amazing.
That to me,
that type of stuff.
I like,
I liked that to have to stop because to me it's like,
it's the raw essence of what this is.
I found out about it from another comedian,
they,
Mike Donovan,
a hilarious guy from Boston,
and he was crying,
laughing,
describing it and describing this bit the dice was doing about Nixon eating ass
fucking,
and he was doing,
this is crazy,
whatever.
It was so ridiculous.
But for whatever reason,
Mike Donovan was,
tears were coming out of it so he couldn't breathe.
He was describing it.
I was like,
God,
I gotta listen to this.
Fucking nice is one of those guys,
when you watch them,
you're like,
this guy can just talk.
Yeah.
And it's funny.
Well,
he's going to interesting.
He's been around for so long and you know,
to me he's always represented to me,
my childhood because when I was like 19 was the first time I listened to his
cassette in my car with my girlfriend and I could,
we were just crying,
laughing.
I couldn't believe how funny was.
Is that what made you with these?
He one of the guys what you will like?
I want to start doing stand up.
Yeah,
for sure.
He was definitely one of them.
Him and Kinison him and kittens and prior,
but prior was see like I remember watching those guys and then watching prior
and we're like,
God prior was so smooth.
He was so the way he was so personable and vulnerable.
He was something different because he was vulnerable.
He would talk about like his life and his problems and all these different
things about being addicted to drugs and all these different Indian,
it was so intelligent,
but vulnerable and honest and,
and the timing was so good.
He was such a master.
I remember we were watching was me and my roommates at the time.
We watched the Kinison special and then we watched Richard Pryor and my friend
who was never a comedian and everyone thought he goes dot fucking guys the best
cause he's just the best.
And it was just,
we were both in agreement like,
yeah,
he's just better.
It's just the way he did it,
you know.
And this is,
you know,
we're talking like 1988 sure.
So it was still fairly fresh and prior was still alive and it was just
different,
you know,
he was,
uh,
he was like the first,
I mean obviously Lenny Bruce was the first really honest comedian like,
or one of the first honest social commentators and then Carlin,
but prior took it to a weird personal place where you like,
we're rooting for him.
It was the most personal of all of those guys because the Hex and Collin were
famously like not personal.
Yes.
And prior was personal.
Personal and,
and you know,
he,
he would like emphasize humanity.
Yeah.
Like you would emphasize like loving each other and being kind to each other.
Like that was a thing.
Yeah,
absolutely.
But,
uh,
you know,
I tell my parents took me to see live at the sunset strip and I was a little
kid.
Oh,
you saw it,
the actual none.
And all of a sudden in the movie theater when a movie theater and that,
that was probably the big seed.
That was the impact.
Yeah.
Because I couldn't believe how funny this guy was just talking.
I remember looking around the theater and these people were like falling out of
their chairs laughing and I'm like,
I can't believe this guy is just talking.
And it's amazing.
Yeah.
Because all these movies that I'd seen that were really funny.
He was a bunch of things happen and explosions and fucking stripes.
Yeah.
But this was not that.
I saw,
I sat Eddie Pepitone tape his special a few days ago at a dynasty,
a typewriter and he's one of those guys who still funny and so electric that you
have a room full of,
you know,
the type of people were kind of talking about your more buttoned up,
the more of that kind of alternative crowd.
They were barking and howling.
And how funny he was and some of the things he said.
The first thing he does,
he grabbed the microphone and he's like,
I'm on Molly.
The hall just exploded and he's one of those dudes I watch and I'm like,
man,
intensity.
Just raw power.
He's announced such a nice guy too.
He's a great too,
if you know him.
Yeah.
Route Forum.
A sweetheart of a car and an odd guy like,
I don't know any other Eddie Pepitone.
No.
That's what makes him so great.
Yeah.
He's,
he's like,
this is an experience and the beat,
to me,
the best comedy,
I think is a comedy where you go,
Oh,
I'm having an experience now I can't have again.
Right,
right,
right.
I can't have this again or especially a live show.
Yeah.
I can't go down the block and see this.
It's not as a steak house.
It's the same in every city.
This is a fucking unique human individual that's having this experience at this
moment,
and I'm lucky to be here with,
yeah.
Yeah.
Live shows,
man.
There's something about it that it's so hard to translate when you,
when you did your Netflix,
but if you did one of the 15 minute ones,
how many they're doing a lot of those,
which I think is a good move.
Four to 5,000 jobs.
It's a great movie.
It's a great move to have everyone have a special,
I think my mother's doing one.
It's very exciting.
Uh,
you don't even have to do comedy and have a special anymore.
You can just sit in a car and talk.
That's my next admission tape will be me speaking in a,
in a car going through an in and out,
um,
bill burrs videos of him driving around his fucking 40 funnier than just talking
about,
this is the funniest thing.
Most specials.
Um,
the Netflix,
he was a lot of fun,
but here's the reality.
I watch it back and I'm like,
it was fun.
Or in the room,
you know,
it's just one of those things,
I bet.
Bring the pain was better in the room even though it's amazing.
Right,
right.
You watch that and you're
like,
this is the highest heights of anything.
Yeah.
That's why when someone makes you laugh really hard on a special God,
imagine what it'd been like being there.
Oh yeah.
I mean the,
the comedy is an act I have one of my friends always says comedy should be seen
live in,
and listen,
there's something different about a smaller venue,
like when people go see what the store,
there's something different than seeing you in a theater.
The level of intimacy,
you know,
seen you work stuff out,
seeing you in,
you know,
in the moment.
There's something different about that 100%.
Yeah.
I like 150 to 300 seat room.
That's what I like.
But I also,
I like 11,000 seats too.
It's kind of crazy.
It's fun in a weird way.
That's amazing.
And if you could make those people like feel like it's intimate,
it's uh,
it's like,
uh,
you can,
you can treat 11,000 people the same way you treat the main room.
A hundred seat room that's filled with about 80 people.
That's good too.
This is low expectations.
What I like.
I like a big room full of the very small amount of people and they could sit
back and get really drunk and that were lax.
All the wait staff home shut off most of the lights.
Yeah.
There's something,
there's something going on when you're doing a live performance that no one's
ever really quantified.
It's some kind of a mass hypnosis or some energy transfer because I was an actor
for when I was a kid.
I was six years old to 12.
I was an actor.
You know your parents' idea.
Oh it was my idea,
Joe and uh,
like most six year olds or six.
Yeah,
it was great.
I was,
I knew what your cabaret license,
it was on sesame street twice.
We really,
for it to all legit.
Was It really your idea?
Yeah.
I pointed at the TV and said,
well,
unless my parents are lying cause I don't remember and they are liars.
So they needed muddy all south.
They said,
I pointed to the TV and said I want to be on that.
And I just,
and I,
and I made them take me on auditions that maybe they were looking over their
bills and I was a good looking little kid and they said he needs to start
pulling his weight and you know,
we've got to start taking him up.
Yeah,
it was on sesame street.
I was in a bunch of plays and stuff.
That live performance is different.
It's still energy,
but there's nothing quite like being alone on a stage doing comedy.
Well there's all doodle much later.
It's all your shit.
You're writing it,
you're figuring out your per se it,
yeah,
you're crafting it,
putting it together.
And that's why the rejection is the deepest.
How do you write?
I go on stage with an idea and I've started doing these little videos on
Instagram where I actually kind of rant about an issue and if people kind of
respond positively to them,
sometimes I'll take that to the stage and I'll just try to rant about an issue
and like find a few lines that are keepers that are funny and that's,
and then I'll sit down and rewrite it and we look at the bit and re,
but a lot of what I do has to be like,
how does it sound?
What's,
what's the inflection was to pay.
Saying so like being onstage helps a lot.
But there are things that I,
and what's hard for me and what I have to get better about is writing about
things I don't care about somehow.
So like if
like if you said,
give me 50 jokes about the Kardashians,
I,
I would not want to do that.
But why would you need to?
Well,
I'm not saying I do,
but I mean that's a skill some people have.
There's great monologue joke writers and stuff,
but if I see something that's ridiculous that I'm like perplex by or I think is
funny,
I can devote attention and energy into making that funny.
Yeah.
I say just concentrate on that.
Fuck all that other stuff.
I mean that's,
that's what I do.
I am in awe of certain people where you could go,
oh,
here's a topic.
Give me 50 jokes.
And they'll have them and they're good.
But you notice that those guys usually wind up working as writers and they
always,
yeah,
I feel kind of shitty.
That's a lot of them do.
That's not a good guy.
When you're a great comic and you're working as a writer on a Sitcom,
that's a,
that's a bad,
and you were talking about it earlier.
I know a few guys like Owen Smith,
you know,
and I don't know him.
No,
but I've heard the name one of the best fucking standups in the country.
He's so good.
He has his bit.
I don't want to tell you much about it because it's about adopting a white son.
It is one of the funniest bits I've ever seen in my fucking life.
It's so good that you're like,
holy shit,
it's so,
it's so fucking twisted.
And so,
uh,
it's so like you can't believe what he's saying while he's saying,
but this is a guy that is,
I mean skill wise,
one of the best standup comics in the country.
Yeah.
But he's not known for it as much as he's got a real career as a writer,
you know,
and he's trying to branch out and move away from that.
But God damn that guy murders when he's in the comedy store,
I always sit in the back of the room and watch.
Yeah.
When a lot of people,
I guess with families and kids get to make decisions
that already think stuck with me when it's like you want to be doing something
you don't care about.
So to me,
I have to write about things that I'm interested in.
Like,
I think people,
the people's careers that I wanted,
the people that I envy,
their careers seem to be led by their interests.
Yeah.
Things that interest them.
Well that's a better life.
Yeah.
You know,
I,
uh,
I've done both.
I've done,
like when I was doing fear factor,
I wasn't remotely interested in it other than the paycheck and it was a good
gig.
I'm not like,
I'm not shitting on,
it was a great gig.
I love that I had that job.
I love being financially stable,
you know,
at the time I was like,
good,
now I don't have to worry about paying my bills.
It's a nice thing.
It was a great group of people that I work with,
producers and everybody network.
Everyone's great.
But there's such a difference between doing that and then doing a podcast.
Oh yeah,
there's a giant difference.
But that's the way the,
the way that I've kind of done my podcast is like,
what do I care about?
What do I want to know about?
Who can I feasibly get on to talk about it?
Those are the things that are interesting to me.
Not so much like let's just pick a topic that's in the news that everyone will
have a take on.
But I mean even even that,
if that's what you're interested in,
something wrong with that.
Of course,
if you're interested in that.
Yeah,
but it has a comic to have no boss.
So that's something nice.
That's so nice.
These comics a kit,
they get pigeonholed and stuck into these gigs where they don't want to fuck up
the,
so they don't want to say anything controversial.
So their material gets bland and some of them take these big moral stands and
it's like,
well,
you're making a crazy amount of money.
Like some of them are like,
I won't work here and I will work.
If that person is on a lineup,
I won't do it.
And I'm like,
yeah,
but you're making a lot of money that,
that drives me crazy.
It's crazy that I'm not going to work with,
unless someone's stealing.
Right.
Just stop.
Unless someone is stealing or they're punching people or there being a rapist or
something.
I mean this is something so egregious.
They should probably be in jail.
Like what?
You got creative differences.
You fucking baby,
get over it.
Just get up there.
Yeah.
I've worked with a lot of people.
I don't enjoy working and I don't have the luxury of light,
you know,
I'm going to,
I won't work this venue because this person worked here.
It's like that's it.
That's good.
You know?
Well,
I still don't,
I mean at the store that this,
I'm there all the time with people I don't even hardly know.
Right.
You know what I mean?
You're,
you're on a lineup with 1415 people.
Yeah.
That,
but that's good too.
That's true to half of those people could be rapists more than half.
Right.
So that sounds like who is definitely,
it's a clip right there.
Depends on whose definition the actual rape.
Right now it's like words,
right?
You gotta be fucking careful.
Trill.
That's where we come in.
That's where it's very confusing,
right?
Because we as comics,
especially comics like you and I that say fucked up shit,
you can get away with things that are really not supposed to be in society
anymore.
So sometimes people will get up and leave and like it's fine to believe like,
hey,
I'm joking.
Don't you get that?
You drunk in a room,
isn't it 1130 at night,
eight or your if you perform earlier.
But with me,
I'm like,
isn't it 4:00 AM what's the problem?
Right?
If you can't take this opinion now when you get a tick,
yeah,
and sometimes it's not good.
Yeah.
Sometimes the materials,
not those Parkland kids had never worked where I said,
I don't want anyone to get shot,
but the kids,
these kids are knowing these five are annoying.
I said,
I don't want anyone to get shot.
I don't want any.
So I said,
let's ban guns.
But first we have to shoot these kits.
We have to kill the pocket kits.
These five,
we have to shoot the phones out of their hands and they're going to be the last,
and we could explain to them,
we're going to go,
we're banning guns.
You'll be less five people to ever die.
And it didn't work.
And people's people were not exactly thrilled with it,
but it's like you should be able to trust,
you should be able to try.
You've got to trust sometimes like,
you know,
you were saying you go onstage with a premise and then in the middle of doing
that premise,
you'll find the beats.
Sometimes you don't find the beats and he think maybe there's something there.
I've,
I've had a few bits where I was sure there was something there.
I've never been offended by a joke.
That's me personally.
Like I've never,
have you ever been offended by a joke?
No,
I've never been offended,
but I've been like,
oh,
that one wasn't good.
You,
but that's normal.
Yeah.
It's um,
the,
the finding the beats on stage in front of a live crowd too.
There's something about that high wire act that makes your brain go to these
weird places that comes up with punchlines.
You have to fucking find a punchline.
You have to find something funny.
You have to,
these people paid money.
It's like,
dude,
it's like waving a steak in front of our junk
yard dog and you keep tossing them little bits and then eventually like you
don't have to tromp mistake and sometimes there's no punchline.
This is part of the fucking Gig.
Then you got to shit.
Trump rally just screaming.
She sent us.
If he doesn't get elected,
do you think he goes and starts a podcast TV network he took?
Totally could.
Yeah.
He totally could probably be better for him,
honestly.
That's what he thought he was gonna do.
I think before he got elected,
I think he was having high level meetings with people in the media space to
start something like that.
Well,
once NBC fired him and BC fired him while he was running because of the stuff
that he said about Mexico and the thrill of rape is someone's doing the raping,
right?
To Hey,
talk to this.
So fucking crazy out of control for a person running for president.
NBC is like,
that's it.
We're getting rid of you.
And then they put Arnold in his place and that was a disaster.
Do you remember that?
People Forgot Arnold,
the host of the apprentice.
You'll fire.
Yeah.
Was it was horrible.
It was terrible.
Trump was shitting on them.
Did they just scrapped the show after that?
Here's a question.
Does he go back to the apprentice?
Well,
if NBC has had the presidency,
I think he's too toxic.
Toxic,
toxic.
Maybe you could come up with something like that for Fox.
Oh,
Fox is in the scoop him up.
That's what's great about Fox.
They'll play ball,
play ball.
They're not going to leave money on the cable.
You know what though?
They did want Megan Kelly back to like,
well she did a thing.
I used to do the show red eye on Fox News,
which was comics would just try to be funny.
It was the air did it like 3:00 AM east coast time and I saw her the week she
was doing that and she was in like the dressing room and she knew she shouldn't
have left.
She can feel it.
She had already made the decision,
but you could kind of see it in her face that I think she knew that she was
going to try to be this daytime TV queen and like,
let's bake cupcakes.
You know,
I just spent four years on Fox News talking about Santa Fe and white,
but now let's bake cupcakes cause I'm,
I'm America's sweetheart.
That's never going to work.
Well,
it's weird when you publicly change your image,
it's insane.
Publicly changing your image.
Her shirts or skirts got longer.
Oh yeah,
she covered her neck or yeah.
You know,
it was no more cleavage.
Every show was about sexual assault.
She was trying to make,
every single show is about sexual assault.
I think she was trying to ingratiate herself in with the people that hated her,
which is like the New York media types.
The people that did not like her.
And then she was like,
but it wasn't even just about sexual assault.
One of them was a lady who fuck Matt Lauer and she knew she was fucking him and
she was talking about a lot of shit.
Fucked him.
Well,
I didn't know any better.
I was 25
25 if fuck the guy,
fuck what happened.
It's bad here.
Right?
Well he shouldn't have fucked it cause he was married.
Okay.
After that,
what happened?
What's going on then you just fucked him.
But who cares?
Why is this a segment of a show?
Is it because it's scandalous?
Get an interview with her.
Great.
Yeah,
it was like,
you know,
and she was saying,
I was young and I was impressionable.
Sure.
Of course.
It's funny to see them all put nails in each other's coffins.
Right.
He's not great.
Media is like this blood feud.
There's only a few families that control all of this information.
They all hate each other.
That's why succession is such a great show.
Well I think with Megan it was like that.
She had been sexually harassed while she was at Fox News going after all those
two gals.
Yeah.
So she was going after and I think bill O'Reilly too.
I think there was some something he paid 38 million.
So it's like,
what did he do?
I think it was 32 32 and 38 guy and my grants,
my grandfather still hasn't bill O'Reilly patriots welcome doormat.
Wow.
You know it's a good Matt.
I mean a mansion.
That's a giant amount of money.
It's the amount of money where what he did should be,
I mean it seems like it's an,
it could be a Netflix documentary.
Let's going to be hot.
It's like horrific.
Like he offered her 37 million.
She's like no,
keep going.
Yeah.
Right.
I'm going to need more after what you did to me is a $32 million offense.
We'll do.
Is that one recording that had left on some assistance entry and macrus woman.
Yeah.
Touch loofa sponge or something.
That's what he was trying to do.
That's how creepy old guy move.
Get you with a sponge to an interesting,
he tried to have his ex wife.
You tried to have his ex wife excommunicated from the church.
What great did it.
Oh he tried.
I mean know the why.
Well cause he wanted her to go to hell.
A church.
You do what kind of donation you have to make to get your ex wife sent to hell?
Probably 32 million.
He's got it,
but he wanted her ex communicated.
That's type of guy.
He is.
Well,
the crazy thing is even after all this,
the guy's still had the number one book in The New York Times because people dig
it.
They still,
those old fuckers,
they just give in.
They dig in,
they don't care.
They like him.
They might know who he is.
Folksy.
He's like my uncle.
He's a good man.
He's spent $40 million for some woman.
He touch it.
The tide goes in,
the tide goes out with God.
I'm with God.
That what he was doing that that fucking Todd goes in,
the tide goes out.
You can't explain it.
One.
I was like,
wow,
you went to Harvard,
you fucking piece of shit.
Yeah.
Well you could explain that those guys are,
they were religion like a fuck.
It's fashionable to wear it.
They wear it.
They know
Trump does.
He gets out and he goes,
I'm a Christian.
I may not be the best Christian,
but I'm a Christian leadership quality enough.
It's good enough.
You know?
And you're like not the best Christian.
You're a thrice married guy who owns gambling and a Miss Universe pageant.
You're a biblical fig that's like a biblical figure that would be like a Roman
king that everybody was warned about like gay in terms of like,
I mean,
I want him to shave his head.
What do you think that will do?
I just freedom.
I think it would funny if you shaved it like somebody had a cancer issue and he
just shaved it with them to be a good guy.
Well,
it doesn't look good.
That's what's confusing to me.
Like when I realized as a style,
when my hair wasn't looking good,
you got rid of,
it was impossible to look good.
It was fallen out to the point where like,
this is just a mess.
Then I went and buzzed it,
but he,
uh,
I just can't this to my generation,
I always remembered she would like the,
just the herald virile.
Yeah.
It's nice.
I've been,
I've been like this for a long time.
Yeah,
I'm solid.
Eight plus years bald.
You want Trump to just go,
hmm.
I think you'd be better off.
It'd be easier.
Like he's not good looking.
He was know that he would,
that would complete his transformation into a supervillain,
I guess like a Lex Luthor type Gal.
Yeah,
but it just like,
I just
gotta be so much work to put that hair together.
I think someone does it from,
but even then you've got to talk to them while they're putting it together.
I bet you he hasn't talked to them.
Everything.
He does just tweets angry.
I bet he's not concerned with the human relations with his staff.
No.
Let's just get that vibe.
Five.
I get that.
Five,
the person who's in charge of the hair just does the hair.
I hope he retired when he retires or when he's done.
I hope he goes right into podcasting.
Would you have them on right now?
Yes.
Yeah,
of course.
You have to.
Yeah,
yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
Why not?
Why wouldn't he come on a three hours hours?
He's busy and I had some jokes about them.
He's petty.
He hates comedy.
He does not like to be made fun of.
He doesn't like to be made fun of.
I'm sure Michelle Wolf got him on Twitter a few times of correspondence center
and he went after her,
but she can't write back at him and shit.
I bet you'd be on my side if I killed the journalist.
Yeah.
Michelle is a kill shot.
Kill Shot.
You're not going to win.
Yeah,
she's,
she's snuffed him out and she'll just forget it.
He just dropped off the face of the earth without always duck out and it was
done.
She neutered him one tweet.
Neutered.
Yeah.
There's some people that go after him though and it doesn't work and he doesn't
respond that it looks so weird.
It's weird when I see my aunt tweeting at him,
I'm like,
what do you think this is going to do?
My aunt with 43 followers,
she say,
um,
you were disgusting representation of this country.
She'll tweet this and then I have another hand who's the other side that'll be
like,
I believe in you keep going.
And I just imagined him scrolling through these messages and reading this.
Do you think he looked,
looks at and he,
I think he only looks at verified accounts.
I think he's got,
like if you're thinking about how many people he follows on Twitter,
I think if he's wise,
he doesn't see the mentioned.
I'll tell you right now,
his biggest fans are not verified.
His biggest fans and not have a blue check are under a hundred followers.
They have dog like the,
his biggest fan,
not just the people that voted for him.
The people that are still like in love with them.
A lot of them have dog profile pictures like a dog that recently died.
There's a lot of dead dogs,
floating flies,
book flags and the banners and Marilyn,
none of them have ever served in the military.
Right.
But they will have the flag.
They all have the flag.
No one's ever served.
And I'm 43 to 48 followers.
Magda,
I know in the proffer Hashtag Maga Hashtag Mag,
you know,
a lot of them aren't real.
Do you know that?
What are they,
the Russian bots?
It's real.
Yeah,
it was a guy in Russia who's got that job.
It's not kind,
it was personnel on long island.
There's a lot of people that have them.
They have various accounts they use interested.
There's a woman named Renee duressed it,
she's coming on the podcast soon.
She did a study of this for,
uh,
I forget what she did it for,
but she was on Sam Harris' podcast,
which she went in depth with it.
I'll,
I'll send it to you after we're done,
please.
It's fucking amazing.
But they did all kinds of crazy shit.
Like they would have like a pro Muslim group and they would put on a
demonstration right across the street from a pro Texas group.
And they would organize both of them.
They would really,
yeah.
Yeah.
They organize.
So discord,
they would organize,
uh,
African Americans at Kent's,
Hillary Clinton,
anyone but Hillary,
we got a vote for Jill Stein.
We've got to vote for anyway.
And they would like,
she doesn't represent us.
And this is all Russians.
Yeah.
And then they would have other people that were like pro Bernie and then Hillary
fucked over Bernie.
And these were Russians as well.
Hey,
we'll just fall meant coups and overthrowing their leaders.
It's nice.
It will just kill their people.
We don't fuck with their social media.
I think we fuck with her social media.
I'm sure we do.
I'm sure there's,
like I wrote off a lot of that Russian stuff is like people's wishful thinking,
but the more and more I read about it,
the more there is like a coordinated attempt seemingly to institute this social
media and so this girl,
yeah,
there's 100% a real thing going on because this woman documented it and two,
it was also really funny like she was talking about how many of the memes that
they created that were really funny.
Oh,
they're hilarious.
And they came out of Russia.
So there's a bunch of guys in a room in Moscow creating memes and it's so funny.
This is like they went to KGB training or whatever it is now FSP,
and this is where they ended up just hiring people.
This is the frontier of the war against the United States.
The thing is though,
if they can do that and get people really upset if they really can't do it,
that's a really effective strategy.
It's a great strategy.
Can make things happen now cause it's just sewing internal discord and we're
going to collapse her own system.
Like I wonder how many of these Jesse Small lay a is that I see his name,
Jesse smell A's,
Russian.
The whole thing is rushing.
Not even real thing is rushing.
Jessie Smollett doesn't exist.
I wonder how many of the memes were created by Russians to try to get people
upset.
I bet there's bunch.
I bet there's more people stirring things up then just Temaze Americans that are
upset.
I know,
I'm sure it's people that are,
but then there's also just a lot of Americans that hate each other.
Does that?
Yeah.
There's that.
But then you also,
what do you think happens with Jesse?
Small light his empire because ABC got rid of Roseanne for tweet.
You got to get rid of this guy.
I thought he was getting canceled.
He was getting written out rather.
Did I read today?
But yeah,
I don't know.
I thought he was getting written out before and this is one of the reasons why
he did it.
Well,
I support him if that's the case,
cause he's a very hard business.
This is a very tough business.
It is hard.
It's hard to make it.
I loved that they had to plan that out and he said to the two guys,
he goes,
listen,
get a noose.
Yeah,
cool.
Get rope and doing this.
All a lot of these hate crimes,
it,
first of all,
I hate crimes happen and they're horrible.
But some of these things are fic.
Do you know he showed up at the hotel with the new still around his neck holding
a subway sandwich.
Just that alone,
the people,
the people at the hotel should have been like,
what?
What happened?
That's amazing.
Okay,
what happened?
Why Sandwich juice?
It's still at the sandwich.
And why are you eating at subway or you're not sick to your stomach or on
empire?
What the Hell's wrong with you?
[inaudible] so,
but the subway subway's not good.
It's not bad if you're hungry.
Listen,
I've clearly hating it,
but it ain't great.
But if it's like two o'clock in the morning,
it's the only thing open.
Why is he open to 2:00 AM that's a great place.
It's open.
It's a good move to be open when nothing else is open.
It's a good point.
You get a nice Italian.
So I would double meat.
I like to have the oil and vinegar,
salt and pepper ball with the Mozzarella,
whatever.
And then you don't toast it.
You let the hot and meatballs melt the cheese.
Oh,
I agree with that.
Yeah.
That's a good move.
And he posts up.
It's always a good mark.
Especially after faking a hate crime
after he was the hate crime.
I meet both.
How nervous you after you do that?
I'm such a pussy.
I could never go.
I could never do what.
He did some level associates,
but then I saw that act right dinner with the other night and I went,
oh he could do that.
Yeah.
Oh these people can do it cause they were on another level.
Well the other thing is that people say who would want to be a victim?
Who'd want to fake being a victim?
I heard that during the cabin off hearing.
I was like,
that is a ridiculous thing to say.
Cause there's a lot of currency in our business,
in our business.
It's a lot of conflict.
Yay.
In the world.
Like people like praise victims for showing out and they support them.
You get a tremendous amount of love,
especially if you're a legit victim.
Something of course,
you know,
I mean there's a lot to that.
Yeah.
The idea that no one would do that is so there's so against it.
So contrary to human nature,
everyone would do it.
I want to do it.
What would you do?
What kind of hate crime would you fake?
It was great idea.
I don't know if I got punched and people saw my face,
they'd go good.
It deserved it.
You know what I mean?
Like nobody would look at my face ago.
Yeah.
Okay,
good.
Well I wrote,
I tweeted something today.
I was like,
Hey,
I'm at flappers on a J W was hit.
Uh,
my,
the 26 of flappers I was,
it was two guys was Hollywood would Maga hats.
They beat me up.
They poured something on me.
I don't know what it was.
I think it was come please come to farmers.
But I mean,
that's the thing.
Listen,
I watched good morning America interview this morning.
I left,
I sent it to my buddy.
I go,
there's a moment in it.
When they go,
how'd you know it was he attackers?
And he goes like this.
He goes,
you could see the insanity.
You can see in his eyes.
He goes like this.
He goes,
I was there and he just doing that Shitty actory.
Oh,
like just fucking shitty acting class.
That horse shit.
I was there and I'm like,
this is fucking crazy.
Oh,
he was going to inform on two guys if there were two white guys with Maga hats
who got caught,
they'd be in jail right now because the detective said to him,
we have two suspects on camera.
Do you think it's Sam?
And he's like,
yeah.
Then he found out it's just two buddies and he's like,
well,
I can't testify against them.
He was going to testify against two people who they thought were guilty.
So he said that he thought it was dumb.
Yeah.
There's a good morning America interview.
Oh,
have him going?
Yeah.
It's those two that takes it to another level and then Fox.
He's like,
well,
we start with,
hey,
he's good on the show.
We stand behind them.
That takes it to a completely different than there would be people in jail right
now.
He wouldn't care.
Could you imagine?
It's crazy.
Could you imagine not just faking a hate crime,
but then putting people in jail?
Magic being those two guys were just sitting in jail like,
what the fuck you're on the cover of the New York Post nabbed him,
got him,
got up and they're sitting there like,
what the fuck?
And everybody wants to kick their ass every empire.
Next season is all about Jesse smaller.
They fire everyone else on the show and it's just to Jesse smallest story and
two innocent people.
The Gay Tupac wandering the streets of empire.
That's why people in Ohio,
whenever Hollywood is like,
here's how to vote.
They go,
you know what?
No.
They go,
you know what?
No thank you.
I see what you're doing.
You fucks fake and hate crimes.
What kind of hate crime would you fake if you were going to do it?
It's a great class to get ahead.
That's a great question.
What if,
what if someone gave you a license to fake a hate crime?
Like what if there was a television show about faking a hate crime?
That's how they do like punked,
you know you are fake things like that.
How about you fake a hate crime?
I'd love to do something like that.
True TV presents.
Yes.
Fake a hate crime.
Yeah.
It's interesting.
I don't,
I'm trying to think how this conference a whole deal.
Maybe a Halaal guy would attack me in New York City,
like a Halaal guy would attack me because he views me as a symbol of imperialism
and oppression.
There'll be good,
you know?
Even though I patronize his stand all the time,
he still feels the need to attack.
I mean,
I don't know.
I could never do that.
No.
I'm one of those people who would get,
and I wouldn't get caught.
Well,
this would never think I'd get away with it.
Wanting everyone to think you're a victim when nothing really happened is
insanely selfish thing.
Yeah.
That's an insane like faking physical crime.
Ikea to have someone punch him already hit himself.
Yeah.
These marketers face maggot hat wearing gangs and everyone's talking about in
Chicago and La and New York do not exist.
If you have a maggot hat on at 2:00 AM in New York,
you're getting bleached poured on you.
Yeah.
Probably reality will also like just,
he was saying that he like punched him back and he fought back and I love how he
was like,
first of all he was on camera for everything except one minute.
So they ask them to good morning America.
They go,
how long was this?
He's like,
it felt like several minutes,
but it could have been 30 seconds.
Like he's covering the span of time in his,
in his lie,
he's going,
I got to say it's less than a minute cause I'm only off camera for a minute.
Whenever you heard about a guy like kills his wife and blames a black guy.
Yeah.
You know,
there's been a bunch of those,
right.
It's been a ton of,
and then you see the Energy Simpson for example.
Did he blame something?
What do you know?
Somebody probably blamed him,
you think?
Nah,
I'm kidding.
I remember there was a recent one,
people were saying that his son did it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
My mother always believed that.
But again,
that's so fractured conspiracy theory though.
Right.
And that's why I don't really get into,
I don't want,
yeah,
that's,
those are the ones that are out there.
I don't really get into that.
I don't get any of the moon.
I don't go near a,
I'm not an Oj truther are you a a Gulf of Tonkin guy or operation Northwoods?
Those are all true.
There's nothing,
there's nothing.
Those are all true operation Northwoods is my favorite.
Crazy.
Yeah.
They stay talked about bombing a ship.
With people on it.
And they were going to blow up a drone jetliner and blame it on the Cubans.
They were gonna.
They were gonna attack Guantanamo Bay arm,
Cuban friendlies and have them attack autonomo crazy.
Yeah.
That was not,
that was not that long ago.
I know.
That's why we need you back.
I can't do it.
We know what mercy's are too fucking.
It's too exhausts.
I got exhausted cause I would do a shell and then somebody would come up to me
after this show and they'd be like,
they'd show me a pizza menu.
I swear to God.
And they go,
you see that?
And I got nice.
Well what is it?
They go,
that's the nambla symbol.
And I'm like,
it says like it says garlic knots.
And they're like,
no.
They're like,
you had to really look at it.
Oh.
And I'm like,
all right,
I can't go with the rest of my life with that.
Well they look for it and everything.
Everything's a conspiracy.
And then when it comes back to you and they say,
oh,
Tim is involved in this,
right?
And then you go,
oh,
I see how this works.
You don't just make shit up.
Yeah.
And then they believe it.
The CIA is now getting involved in podcasting.
Yes.
Do you guys,
you're their first shelf,
but they're going to get a few others on the deeply involved in.
Steve started the rush and Troy,
I love the idea of the CIA going and watching PSATs and be like,
who's getting passed at the store?
Oh,
you don't know.
I have a friend of mine who thinks that the CIA started Jim Morrison and Jimi
Hendrix.
There's a book about that called Weird scenes inside the canyon written by a guy
named Dave McGowan and I'm going to tell you right now,
Joe,
it's kind of interesting.
I'm going to tell you,
There was a lot of shit going on in Laurel Canyon,
I'm sure probably about pussy.
There was a lot of weird shit going on.
The CIA,
the Rand Corp was all over there.
It was a lot of shit happening.
Well,
I'm sure there was a lot of shit happening,
but there is not a fucking intelligence agency in the world that can create a
Jimi Hendrix of course,
and they're not sitting there.
That book was like that.
They were managing the birds.
The CIA was like,
they were like,
no,
it's mister tambourine was like a CIA guy to be like it had marine men's.
Imagine being in that time in the country when everything was just falling apart
left and right around us.
Vietnam war,
Kent State,
just fucking Nixon's the president and it's just chaos left and right.
There's no internet.
Yeah,
everyone's doing drugs.
It must have been wild.
It must've been amazing.
I mean,
I always think about that hunters Thompson quote about,
uh,
you know,
like we talked about the sixties and that in the 70s it was almost like the wave
crested and then just it's crashed act from fear and loathing in Las gas.
Yeah.
But I'm a big,
like I'm a Kennedy Guy.
I think there's something really shady with that.
Yeah,
for sure.
For sure.
And in that book is some amazing stuff about this book that you gave me.
His family of secrets is a guy,
Russ Baker,
who's a legit journalist and it's,
it's been praised by like Dan Rather and Bill Moyers,
I'm trying to get you in this.
Let me tell you right now.
This will get you in.
He went,
I don't have that kind of time.
George h did you know the choice?
H W Bush called the FBI and said that he thought he knew who the killer of JFK
was.
Did you know that?
No,
no.
He called the FBI.
The in Houston.
Hey,
what's up?
It's George George Bush.
I'm in Tyler,
Texas and I think I know who the killer is and he informs on this Guy James
Parrot.
And James Parrot ended up being like one of his staffers.
It was this weird cover story.
He kind of planted and that came out in a memo and there was another mental,
these are declassified FBI memos,
freedom of Information Act.
There was another memo that said after the assassination,
j Edgar Hoover,
Pre George Bush and the CIA.
The problem was George Bush should not have been working for the CIA at that
point.
He should have been just a private citizen.
So it was suggested he was working for the agency for a very long time and he
was made the,
uh,
the director of the agency for one year after the family jewels came out,
which was this whole thing with the CIA,
went to Congress and they admitted that they had done all these things from,
you know,
coups and the fomenting revolutions and countries and they made him the director
for one year after that happened to break to make a clean break from all of the
nefarious activities that the agency had been involved with.
But if you take that memo to mean that he had had an existing relationship with
them,
he was actually just becoming the cause.
No,
it made no sense to anyone.
They were like,
why is this guy that everyone called the lightweight becoming the head of the
CIA after the CIA just admitted to all of these horrible things.
They call him a lightweight.
Yeah,
they called.
Yeah.
He was like,
I think Kissinger had said to Nixon to kissed her,
said to Nixon,
he's a lightweight,
commit him ambassador to China.
He was never a guy that had a serious political capital and he was made the head
of the CIA and then after that memo was on earth,
people were saying,
oh,
he had,
this was an extension of the coverup.
He was being made,
the director at this very interesting time in history because he actually had
worked with the agency forever and he was not at all a lightweight.
He was a serious operator and he was going in there to kind of clean up and
transition them into a new era.
It's,
I'm telling you,
I'm already out you.
Yeah.
How are you out?
I can't listen to them.
It's good.
It's great though.
I need current shit.
I ended up need like Julian Assange.
I need something bright.
I need some Edward Snowden done.
All right.
You know to the Bush anymore.
I'll get an a Sanje buck.
You can get in there.
I'll listen to Abilene and a clinic.
If you read it,
if you,
I'll dabble in the clinic.
If you read a chapter of this.
Yeah.
If you read a chapter,
this,
I give me a cookie.
I don't have a cookie.
And if I do,
I'm taking it.
But you will be.
You'll be,
it's very interesting and it's a well written book cause it's not reckless and
slop.
I'll read the first chapter,
I promise.
Thank you.
I will listen to a buddy of mine gave me David,
uh,
liftings best evidence on the Kennedy assassination and that got me into
conspiracy theorists.
It's like 92 and I get it.
Sure.
You're at the end of the road now where you're like,
this is a lot of people are full of shit in that world.
A Lot,
a lot of them.
And that's what people don't realize.
Well then it gets deeper and deeper and deeper and more and more preposterous.
Have you ever googled Hashtag spaces fake?
No,
but that's sounds,
it sounds amazing.
There is a thriving space is fake community.
Have you ever been in space?
No.
Good point.
Could be fake.
Come back,
come back to us.
Joe.
Prove it.
Come back to it.
Well this is an extension of flat earth.
It's like for people to think the flat earth is too conservative.
They go,
they go deeper.
It's like it's not stupid.
They go deep.
Those flat Earth Cox,
they want to move into space.
They want to go to s spaces bank.
Yeah.
You want to know what's really up spaces face basis.
Fake.
Yeah.
Crazy.
What?
I mean,
I think there are hundreds of thousands of people that think that the earth is
flat.
Hundreds of thousands educated western American human beings that think the
earth is flat.
That is wild.
It is fucking crazy.
It's interesting.
It's a lot of people that just get educated from youtube.
The Guardian actually had an article about it.
I sent it to Eddie and Eddie's laughed at me.
See,
I think Eddie's kind of rational and a lot of ways,
because I had conspiracy talks with him about what about,
well,
yeah,
no,
the one that we had wasn't saying a little government was attacking Malibu.
Well,
he's the one that we're talking about that they were using direct energy weapons
and I was like,
I don't know if this is tacky Malibu with what?
I was like,
why would they attack mallet with of the fires?
But I'm like,
they're rich.
Why would they attack mal boats to rich people?
Fire started here.
My fucking house.
Did he start a mal?
But they flew through the air.
You know I was one of the first evacuated.
Right.
This fucking theories.
You're so stupid.
It's dry a shit.
Yeah.
A fire hits and the winds are going.
Co Did they make the wind?
They made the wine.
I'm sure you always made the wind.
The wind is always been the CIA.
They've always made the wind.
Yeah.
It's fucking,
it's just any,
there's no rest.
There's no peace.
There's no living in the moment.
It's like a certain point.
You got to just don't even want to know because it's horrible things going on.
There's horrible things going on.
Okay.
What do you think is
like the war shit going on right now?
Human trafficking is very bad,
horrible,
and really dollar industry.
That's not subway sandwich.
Artists are paying for that.
Right?
Rich people.
Some of them are involved in some very bad things and they're,
it's their attraction be they're covering their own tracks.
Yeah.
Like that.
Jeffrey Epstein and stuff.
Dude that the Clinton visited the least got to.
I've got some hire anyone with an island
and hanging out with Bill Clinton.
If you have an island and you're hanging out with Bill Clinton,
there's a problem.
Where's the Mataz?
Yeah,
I mean it's a crazy,
all of that stuff is very disturbing and he got a sweetheart deal cause he
wouldn't inform on anyone that was on his plane and now they're low justice
department's looking at that again.
It'll probably be fine.
They'll probably just let it,
you know with a guy like that,
like what?
You know,
how much does he know?
How does it knows every day alive because it's good the,
he's not going to say anything.
Not going to talk.
I wouldn't trust him if he,
I was on that plane.
I think that's the other thing about see the aversion of conspiracies as you go.
Like nobody would,
people would talk.
The reality is people wouldn't talk if you were from a prominent family.
If it had been like a religion to stay silent.
If you had had CIA training,
if you would,
these people don't talk and we know that there been plots that have gone unknown
for a very long time.
Clearly coup in Iran.
Sure.
So garlic,
Jeffrey Epstein is so involved,
so deep,
he knows he'll get killed.
He won't say anything.
Yeah,
he's not gonna say anything.
Plus he doesn't want to go to jail.
He just want to go to jail.
He doesn't want to say anything.
Middle of the things that he did.
Yeah.
So the,
the,
the child thing is the creepiest of all gross.
And unfortunately it's,
it's a,
it's a real thing.
So you know,
people you could talk about,
there's the conspiratorial angles,
the bullshit.
But then there's the real fathers.
Sandusky,
Catholic Church,
hundred percent.
The people that are in love with conspiracies never care about private prisons
or the Catholic Church.
And I'm like,
guys,
this is not even debatable.
We're not even debating,
right.
Private prisons are ruined.
Kids are being sold into slavery.
Ryan Ababa,
horrible.
The judge in Pennsylvania.
Crazy.
Taking an underage kids and just giving them sentence ridiculous sentences for
shit.
That's crazy.
Exchange for money.
That's not right.
And now he's in jail.
Yeah,
it's uh,
there's some darkness in the world.
It's undeniable.
And when something like San Dusky,
when that Penn state thing comes out and you're like,
wait a minute,
how long was this going on for?
And how many people knew?
Everyone knew.
How does everyone know?
Yeah,
it's crazy.
It turned out just he died quick,
but this is what I'm course but doesn't mean he destroyed.
This is what I mean about people where it's like you tube's gonna like central
conspiracy theory type stuff.
I'm like,
all of those things would have been called conspiracy theories at one point.
Catholic church,
San Dusky blue grade,
they said it was a few bad apples.
It was a labyrinth.
Torture prisoners.
It was a program designed by the Pentagon.
CIA.
It's crazy.
What is the youtube going to do?
They're going to censor recommending.
I think they were stopped recommending conspiracy videos from what I've heard.
But I was reading that thing that you were telling me about Jamie,
this whole like porn or child porn or pedophile network,
you're sending an account of what is this?
A pedophile youtube,
what's going to a communication network.
They were communicating with each other and youtube comments responded yesterday
and they said that they uh,
disabled comments on tens of millions of videos and deleted a lot of accounts
that were,
they were communicating in the comment section of like a little kid's
cheerleading and whatnot.
How were they communicating to try to s to share child porn or were they a
communicating to molest?
Don't know in the way pedophiles communicate and their network.
But
I'd like you to do a little bit more work.
Pull up an article on due diligence on the pedophile.
I want you to go and eat under the dark web burner computer for that download
tor and let's get moving cause we got to figure shit out.
You got to get a VPN or there that's the FBI will take over child points had on
tour and then Ronnie for a year on the talk.
What is that?
What's going on.
I imagine what they see too.
That's a problem.
It is a problem because you're causing,
that happens at our Kelly Case.
There's a video of him doing something with an underage girl and like I think
some people at CNN,
it's like we've seen it but,
and that's led to him going and it's like,
well what did you watch and is that legal?
Probably illegal because you're watching it under the guise of Oh,
journey out of
rough.
Yeah.
That kind of Shit is real.
And the fact that there's these networks of people that are trying to,
you know,
cultivate these experiences.
It's crazy man.
But if you're a rich person,
you have that sick predilection,
you're going to find a way to think of what they're doing.
Like for example,
the post her remarks that praise the girls ask whether they were wearing
underwear or simply carried a string of sexually suggestive emojis.
Bout two years ago,
hundreds of companies pulled money from Youtube over concerns about ads showing
up next to problematic content from terror or hate groups and videos a seem to
endanger exploit children.
I think,
you know,
we've talked about this before with youtube with the issues that we've had with
them.
They,
they have way too much content and way too few people.
There's no way they can watch all of it.
And when Shit like this where people were doing things in the comments,
it's almost impossible to check.
Yeah.
I mean it's just,
cause they're youtube comments are one of the rare free range sort of like
unchecked message boards in the world.
I'm sure I'll find out later.
Read it.
Don't read it Bro.
Who is this fat fuck?
He's not even a black Valerie.
Yeah.
Why is he here?
Who is that dope?
Read it.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Um,
I wonder if there's ever going to be a time where that is impossible,
where like these child pedophile rings,
they can figure out a way to snuff all that out.
I'm,
I'm harder now than ever before.
I'm imagining.
It's very tough and it's tough I think because so few people want to believe
that it's a problem in the way that it is,
right?
Because there's good people in the world that don't think these things are
issues.
So I think there's the political will isn't there because people don't,
aren't really,
they don't understand that it's,
you know,
and then the people that are doing these things are very wealthy,
powerful people,
and they have a lot of control and they can kind of cover their tracks.
If they're were all wealthy on all empower,
poor pedophile,
you're not going to a ring.
What are you doing?
You snatching some kid,
oh,
I know it's bad.
But if you're rich,
pedophile,
it's a nicer experience.
It's like you go on vacation versus me going on vacation,
you go on vacation.
It's a nice experience.
I go on vacation,
you know,
it's fine.
Sandals in The Bahamas,
not even no sales where you go in the cabin or something in the forest.
You know what's crazy about all of us when you're talking about like child
molesters and stuff like that,
which crazy is the Catholic church is still around and still they're catching
people left and right when it's known for it.
There's no more,
no,
nothing is more synonymous with child molesting.
Then the Catholic church.
That is the number one thing.
You were raised Catholic.
I was raised Catholic.
I was never molested.
Um,
you got lucky,
Huh?
I was lucky.
I was fake chem labs Kat.
We're all fit.
This Catholic is fake.
It's,
it's stuffed shells.
It's a nice dinner.
It's five fishes once a year.
It's like no one cares.
No one in a Catholic church cares.
If you turn around to the guy next to you though,
is this bull shit.
They'll go shut up.
I said I'm a bit about it.
I don't understand the suicide bombers cause I was raised Catholic.
Right.
And no one is in the Catholic Church believes in it that much.
We like nice buildings,
Catholic suicide bombers,
and be like,
you go first.
Yeah.
You go for,
I'll be over here.
Do it together.
Ready,
set,
go.
Are you still here?
Yeah,
it's our flux.
Nice architecture.
It's beautiful.
It's great.
It's nice.
It's fun.
I don't know what's going on in them.
There's incense going around.
This is the mystery of faith.
Oh good.
I was talking with Bob about this recently about church has some good qualities
and one of the things that it has is it makes you feel like,
you know,
it's like a community thing.
You sit down and you get a chance to assess yourself and your life and sort of
reaffirm your moral guidance in your moral compass.
And there's some,
there's some,
there's some positive things to a good church and that's how those rock and roll
culty Super Hollywood churches get started because people say,
I want a church.
I just don't want a traditional church.
I want something spiritual and funds and killing.
It's not like the church.
When I grew up,
I said to my dad,
why do we go here every Sunday?
He went,
shut up.
That was the answer because it was like,
we just go,
you go,
you guys don't want your mom to get mad.
But people in Hollywood and people that they,
you know want the hip work,
they want to be drawn to it.
They want it to speak to them.
Yeah.
They played rock and roll music and religions call.
My soul is,
you know,
and it's,
it's just a lot of horse shit.
It is shit.
It makes them feel good.
Yeah.
My Buddy's a assistant and a buddy of mine who was his assistant was going to
one of those church.
She was a NYMPHOMANIAC and she was trying to stop fucking everybody,
so she started going
to church.
What church is that?
The Stop fucking around church.
She'll just start fucking get spiritual.
She's like,
I'm going to be celibate.
I'm like,
Eh,
whatever.
Yeah.
She was one of those gals.
She'd just have a couple of pops and then off to the races.
Listen,
you live lunch,
you live.
Once she was on,
she was attractive.
She was having a good time.
Yeah.
I don't see the problem.
What church did she go to?
This one of them cracked.
I Dunno,
this is decades ago,
but it was one of them.
Crazy rock and roll type churches.
Oh,
that's so funny.
You know the Catholic I,
I think it's interesting that people that joined the Catholic religion now,
oh,
that's ridiculous.
Who's joining it now?
Yeah.
Who's going in and going,
you know what?
I enjoy it.
I don't know who did it.
You know Glenn Beck joined the Mormons as a grown man.
Well,
that makes sense.
That makes sense.
Yeah.
It's a little off.
Maybe one the nine whys.
Yeah.
It's probably why you're sort of course did.
So it's a huge benefit.
Do you know the,
the whole Mitt Romney store?
No.
You don't know?
I don't know.
So I have my cousin married a Mormon who they excommunicated from the church
when he was like 17 Mitt Romney's family all moved to Mexico.
That's why Mitt Romney's dad could never be president because meant Romney's dad
was born in Mexico because when they passed the law making polygamy illegal in
the United States,
they all packed up their shit and went to Mexico.
Really?
Yes.
Because in the 18 hundreds it didn't fucking matter if you were in Mexico or the
United States,
it was all the same.
You're riding a horse everywhere.
Fuck.
They're like that could have nine wives over here.
So they have these compounds.
Vice did a whole series.
Now they have compounds down there with the armed guards.
Yeah,
because the cartel was fucking kidnapping them and shit.
Interesting.
So Mitt Romney's dad was like,
you can't take nice fucking guys.
They still have a fucking,
they still have a compound down there in the Smithsonian magazine,
but is that the smithsonian.com au has a story on it?
Yeah,
the Romney's Mexican history.
the whole family.
That's what I meant from Mexico.
Amazing.
That's amazing.
It's amazing.
They,
I know they went down there because they couldn't do what they wanted to do in
the United States.
There was no polygamy in the u s anymore.
Anyone?
No,
that's legal interest.
It's just hilarious.
Yeah.
Let it happen.
Because here's the thing,
you could have like nine girlfriends.
Sure.
And I'll live together and no one could say shit,
but as soon as you write it down,
it's a prop you up and put you in jail.
There was a show called like sister wives or something.
It was about people that,
I think they were living in the state and then like multiple wives.
Was it?
Yeah,
it's probably bullshit.
Okay.
I don't think polygamy Google it.
Maybe it's like legal in like
Nebraska or some shit.
Sorry Nebraska.
I liked it.
Then Brasco would be just a place to go.
You know what?
Let live and let live live and let live.
Live Rask is like,
we're having a hard time keeping people here so you can just fuck anything.
Anyone you want Mary,
your dog,
Mary,
everything is polygamy nationwide,
federally illegal.
It is illegal.
But I know what you're talking about where there is TV shows where people are
still doing it.
So also have you successfully infiltrated a pedophile youtube group yet waiting
for the tweet.
So Lazy.
But it is crazy that his family was like,
well fuck it.
We'll just move to Mexico and he made a great point.
It's the same thing.
You're on a horse back then.
Yes.
To Rio Grande.
Yeah,
because I think when they made it illegal in the 18 hundreds look at us as a
polygamous community crumbles.
Sister.
Wives are forced from homes.
This is the caliber of life.
This is interesting.
Saw you get bro.
If you want nine of them,
you don't get nine good ones.
You need to get one 10 or not in ones.
This is a lot of,
you know this is,
you don't think of nine shitty wives.
No,
you don't think of nine horrible wives,
but the thing is you could have those wives.
You just can't have them legally let you.
They can't be legally your wife,
but you could do like a whole like roots jump over the broom.
You know you could,
you could.
You can make your own ceremony.
Of course he just can't register in the courthouse,
which is hilarious to me.
Like who the fuck are you to tell someone that can,
all right.
How about a woman that has five husbands?
Can we do that?
Yeah,
you go girl.
Power.
Power for ground for it.
I'm for polygamy.
Me Too.
I want to come out short on this show.
Five cucs and one woman.
Who Cares?
I'll sit around stroking their half our dicks waiting their turn crying.
Perfect.
That is a perfect representation of 2019 America.
Who would vote that out?
Who would say no to sick people?
Someone was a communist.
We need more people getting the youtube pedophile cults out.
Yes.
And putting the polygamous sin.
We need priorities.
I feel like if you want to marry a guy with 18 year friends who gives a shit.
Yeah.
I guess the problem is the divorce.
Isn't that the issue of money for you?
Sorry,
I'm splitting it up 18 ways.
You're not going to get a lot,
right?
Anyone with 18 of anything?
Unless you're like assaulting,
you probably don't have a ton anyway.
Unless you Jeff Bezos.
Yeah.
Well that was a kid.
He could marry a hundred chicks and give them all a billion.
Gotcha.
How sill that 50 leftover.
What?
Yeah,
he's doing good.
He's doing good.
But that whole thing with him,
that was an interesting thing.
The uh,
the pictures being leaked and it turns out it's the brother that leaked the
pictures.
I love the brother immediately.
As soon as I read the article,
because I'm like,
this is Trump supporter.
Not only is your Trump supporter,
this is a guy who tried to leverage himself forever and he found out his history
was fucking Jeff Bezos.
Can you imagine the night he found that out?
The night he found that out.
Where was he?
What was he doing?
He was somewhere thinking,
this is it.
She's fucked.
A lot of people that are good now.
She's fucking basis now.
Some cash in now it's time to think of something good.
How do we do it?
This is a plot guy.
Yeah.
I wonder what the enquirer gave him.
How much money you get for something like that?
Half a mil.
Bayzos Dick.
I want more.
I want a solid mill.
Solid male.
You think your life,
he's going to kill you.
You think he will?
If he doesn't,
I'll be disappointed.
It's a good point.
Make it look like an accident.
If you're a fucking,
you know
he's,
he's like daddy Warbucks.
Yeah,
he's the guy.
He's the guy.
He's got a hundred automated,
automated everything and Amazon's like notoriously like he's an alien.
He looks like he's artificial intelligence.
He's Ai.
Yeah.
He has that look already.
He's super smart and he's going to play it real slow.
Yeah.
Helen's slave the world and you know what?
Let him,
he's probably going to hire somebody to fuck up that guy's life slowly.
I'm sure he already has.
Yeah,
we'll slow.
This is your new job.
Your new job is to slowly make that guys lodash everything.
Everything.
Flat tires every day.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I love the henchman that's going at nailing flat tires set up.
He's going to check for cameras.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
The paint,
the base says those are the new type.
Like cause I studied a lot about like Rockefeller,
Carnegie,
guys like that and those guys,
nobody's,
he amassed a fortune of those guys.
Had Rockefeller at like 336 billion in today's dollars.
Laura Carnegie at 372 billion.
I mean these,
these were the first,
how much did they have in their time?
Ah,
cause the questions and their time,
I don't know,
but in,
in it was millions.
Well I don't think it was billions,
but in our time it's about,
it's the over 300 million.
Both of them.
These were the first generation of B,
B.
This was the first generation of Robert Bat.
Like the first generation of entrepreneurs,
you know,
the country was new,
all of these industries would just emerging and these guys took it over.
Bayzos tech is,
and somebody said,
it's on my podcast recently.
Tech is the closest thing we have now to that where you have these,
you know,
masters of the universe that are going to be,
I mean those guys would be,
JP Morgan was like bailing the government out.
These guys had an insane amount of power.
Um,
they what's really,
really interesting figures.
Yeah.
I was just,
when I told you I was doing this,
chariots of the gods lunch today with a bunch of very influential people and one
of them said,
it's really ironic that apple used to be think different and that was the whole
thing about silicon valley.
Think different now.
It's don't think different right now.
Now let's streamline everybody into one acceptable thing.
Yeah.
Now it's literally you have to think the way everyone else is thinking.
You have to believe what everyone else believes,
even if it's ridiculous.
I think a lot of that is they want to just make money and sell things and they
don't want any discord.
They just want to sell,
make money,
sort of.
But it seems like,
I don't think,
cause they don't band people after they do the things they banned him after
there's a public outcry.
So to me they're not,
they don't have any real values.
Their values are tangible and the values are influenced by public opinion and
where media is.
The values aren't like when somebody says
something,
let's ban him right now this goes against our thing.
A lot of it is if you wait until there's enough dust kicked up,
then they will ban somebody.
Right.
That's true.
So to me,
I get in arguments with friends when they were like their ideological,
I'm like they have an ideological bent certainly,
but their profit seeking enterprises that just want everyone to be happy.
I think if it was up to Twitter,
every tweet would be some type of branded ad.
And on top of that,
now the ideology is skewing and leaning in that direction in terms of like tech
and sure,
there's money in that.
There's money in holding that line and those guys are the ones that are as
powerful as Rockefeller and Carnegie and JP.
Like all of those guys,
they are the next generation of people who will,
their amount of powers is unmatched anywhere in society they're,
they're getting,
they're branching out more and more.
Like the Amazon is now going to have a,
an electric car.
They're investing in that new,
what's it called?
Rivan ravion some new electric car company that's that uh,
Bayzos is investing in.
They're investing in space travel.
They're investing in all these different,
I mean,
he's not going to get poorer and more and more rich.
No,
he's gonna take over everything.
I mean,
these luck we have,
you cannot doubt,
you can't opt out of these systems.
You have to be involved to live a normal life.
You have to be online.
Did you see how someone tried to use to go online,
live their life without Google?
Amazon,
good luck.
A few other things.
And apple and they said they couldn't do it.
Now are you should fear is the only one who can do it with a flip phone.
He's barely doing it.
He's on his iPad using his friend I messages.
He messages me all the time,
all the time,
pretend these.
But I think I give them that.
I'm impressed that he still has a flip phone.
Well he,
he knows that he's an addict,
you know,
he knows and he's an honest man,
and he's like,
fuck this,
this is just too much of my life.
He's right.
He'd be checking social media constantly and,
and also if you're,
you know,
your controversial like he is,
a lot of people are talking shit to him and that would hurt his feelings and
saying mean things to him.
And social media has gotten to the point where I'm on it all day and I'm like,
I'm not having any fun.
No.
It's really gotten to the point where,
what does this experience,
Facebook is a nightmare.
It's elderly people screaming at each other.
This was a website where kids were trying to get laid in college.
This is elderly people screaming and complaining.
They can't afford knee operations and I'm just going like this all day.
Yeah,
it's,
it's not,
you don't get a lot of bang for your buck.
I've dropped off radically over the last six months.
The last six months I've made a giant giant shift away from a reading things and
posting things and just,
I like look at it and look for a couple seconds and then I'll put it down on a
hope your post.
Yeah.
I'm more engaged.
I'm too fucking busy,
you know.
And so what I'm trying to figure out ways to better optimize my time.
That was one of the first ones.
Stopped reading comments,
stop reading posts,
don't just it mindlessly c shift through Instagram pictures,
looking for something that strikes me as interesting.
I just stopped doing that and it made a big difference in my productivity.
Yeah,
huge difference.
Yeah.
Cause you know when the,
when I phone real recently they started putting that thing on your phone.
We see how much screen time you had.
Oh yeah.
That's crazy.
You look at it,
you're like,
what?
Five hours?
I now is 46 minutes.
That's five hours of nothing.
Yeah.
What did I do?
I get a little out of it.
Right?
I'll go find new stories that can talk about,
but it's like finding,
I found that like finding the perfect blend seems to be letting the stories get
so big that they get to you anyway.
No,
I've got the fringe stories to like the Jesse Small age.
It gets so big you can't hear about it.
Yeah.
And then you hear,
and I love the day that the day when we all found out it was social media is
great today that we all found out he was full of shit because then anyone could
make jokes.
But the three days before that,
everyone is posturing.
Oh,
so thought out.
Right.
But then when it came out that it was all bullshit,
everyone's like,
oh,
let's just have fun.
And even though it's,
you know,
I'm not saying that people aren't getting attacked and things aren't bad,
but this particular thing,
right.
If you can't make a joke about this,
what can you make a joke about?
If you can't make a Joseph,
if you think someone shouldn't joke about this,
fuck you.
Fuck you.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
This is one of those things that it's fucking ridiculous.
Insane.
Holding the subway with the fucking news.
He pled not guilty in court.
No,
he did.
Yes he did.
No,
Jamie,
he pled not guilty on everything.
Right?
He denied all charges.
He
denied all charges.
He's going to take his own life.
I believe they have the check.
He wrote to them.
Check 35 hunch.
Ah,
he wrote a check already.
$500 in cash.
He wrote a check that she has.
The other thing I could get punched in five minutes for free.
I could get beat up so easily.
Why is this guy spending $3,500 well,
not only that,
why do you write a check?
Do you have no friends?
He just,
he just didn't think this through even a little bit.
Yeah.
God dammit.
It's disappointing.
It's kind of funny though.
There's nothing funnier right now.
Well,
I think this is what we need.
You know,
we need to understand the outrage machine a little bit better and one of the
best ways to see it as see manufactured outrage.
Absolutely.
And then you go,
oh okay this is a hustle.
Well the cup and thing was great because people like wishing death on 15 year
old kids and it's like the video comes out exonerates them and then people are
like,
no.
Yeah,
people were doubling down.
People like you can't deny what my eyes saw.
I'm like,
oh yo nuts.
And then I was afraid cause I'm like tweeting things that supported the kids.
But I'm like,
what if the next video,
it's just the kids in Klan outfits like this and just dancing around with,
with torches like Charlottesville.
And I'm like,
well then now I look like an idiot.
Yeah,
you can't,
you don't know what to tell them.
You're better off being an observer.
Yeah,
just split it up into the fray.
He just,
you make little choke sit back.
Yeah.
It's like a gang fight.
You better upstairs standing back and going,
hmm,
I don't want to jump in there.
And every,
every day,
every hour.
Another vantage point of that thing was like,
well,
no,
maybe they are guilty.
Yeah.
You know,
I saw that thing.
It was like a white kid.
I slept,
they encircled the native American guy who was banging the drum.
And I'm like,
fuck these kids.
That's not good.
When you see the first image and you know,
the first image,
which is even crazier,
was put up by a troll account.
Right?
Russians,
I don't know who the fuck it was,
what they know all the problems.
Russian planes that came out of Brazil because I saw something yesterday,
a few shady social media posts fed a viral firestorm over coving and Catholic.
Oh sure.
Why it will happen again.
Yeah.
These co the,
they're doing this on purpose,
the,
they took that screenshot to try to get people angry and it worked.
And then they Twitter found out that it was a bullshit account and banned the
account.
So it's very possible that account was some troll.
Oh No,
it's a troll farm.
Wow.
Yeah.
So that's what they'd say.
We're being manipulated now on a level that is like unbelievable.
Unbelievable,
unbelievable.
And people are furious.
Dude,
I hate to cut this short,
but I gotta get the fuck out of here.
Let's do it.
Tell everybody how to get ahold of you on Instagram and Twitter.
D I.
L.
O.
N.
Uh,
Timothy,
Tim Dillon,
comedy.com we're doing a Gig,
right?
What'd you to tomorrow?
That's right.
Tomorrow at the Improv and 15 shuttle.
He attacks me on the way.
Let's see.
It's going to show up for the news to the subway,
so I hope I get in blackface.
Thank you.
Thank you,
Tim.
Down.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Thanks a lot of fun,
man.